Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 107. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zu einer neuen Ausgabe hier von dem Programm aus dem Wohnzimmer. Beziehungsweise eigentlich sitze ich ja hier in meinem Arbeitszimmer und selten sitze ich hier alleine, so ist es auch heute wieder der Fall. Ich habe einen besonderen Anlass genutzt und hier zwei Leute auf der Durchreise abgefangen, kann man fast sagen. Das Thema heute soll nämlich sein Accessibility oder auch Barrierefreiheit, sicherlich diskussionswürdige Begriffe und um diese Begriffe zu diskutieren und was dahinter steckt, um ein bisschen einzutauchen in diese Welt, begrüße ich einerseits Tomas Caspers und den Jan Eric Hellbusch. Hallo. Ja, freu mich sehr, dass es geklappt hat. Ihr seid beide von woanders. Wo kommst du her, Tomas?
Außernehm von Köln.
Außernehm von Köln und du Jan?
Ich wohne in Dortmund.
In Dortmund. Aber ihr seid heute alle da, denn heute findet hier in Berlin eine Veranstaltung statt. Der sogenannte Biene-Award wird verliehen. Ist Biene eigentlich eine Abkürzung auch?
Ja, aber eine ganz schreckliche.
Eine ganz schreckliche. Die müssen wir jetzt nicht sagen.
Die müssen wir jetzt nicht sagen. Das ist immer so Fremdschämen.
Aber es geht. Hat auf jeden Fall auch eine kleine Biene im Logo. Und kurz gesagt geht es hier um die Verleihung von einem Award oder ganz vielen Preisen sogar für Leistungen im Bereich der Barrierefreiheit, Accessibility, wie auch immer, also Webseiten oder andere Systeme, die sich eben besonders bemühen, den Anforderungen von Anwendern gerecht zu werden, die jetzt nicht unbedingt uneingeschränkt mit ihren Computern so arbeiten können, wie man das vielleicht normalerweise immer erwartet. Ja, bevor wir dann in das Thema mal einsteigen, würde ich natürlich ganz gerne mal ein bisschen noch hinterfragen, was so eure Hintergründe sind. Vielleicht fangen wir mal mit dir, Thomas, an. Du betreibst auch einen Webblog, einfach für alle. Was steckt dahinter und was mich auch interessieren würde, ist, wie bist du so in dieses Thema gekommen? Was ist so dein technischer Ursprung, um in den Bereich zu landen?
Also einen technischen Ursprung habe ich eigentlich gar keinen. Ich bin so der klassische Quereinsteiger, der über den frühen Multimedia- und CD-Rom-Boom Anfang der 90er-Jahre aus einem ganz anderen Job in diese damalige Multimedia-Branche gerutscht ist. Und dann boomte der, boomte sich irgendwann aus. Und dafür kam aber dann das Internet dazu. Und so bin ich da irgendwie quer reingerutscht. Also eine klassische Ausbildung im Sinne von Informatiker oder was Ähnliches bin ich nicht. Ich komme eigentlich eher aus der Gestaltenenecke. Ich mache das aber wie gesagt schon seitdem es das kommerziell genutzte Web in Deutschland gibt. Und habe seitdem immer entweder ganz frei oder fest frei oder fest bei Agenturen gearbeitet. Und hauptsächlich mich mit Konzeption, Gestaltung und dann auch immer mehr natürlich die technische Umsetzung befasst. Was ich gemacht habe, ist in dem Jahr 1998 mit einem guten Dutzend Verrückter zusammen das The Web Standards Project zu gründen. Das waren damals eben so ein paar Leute, die sich auf einer englischsprachigen Mailingliste zusammengefunden haben. Und gemeinsam der Meinung waren, man müsste jetzt mal was gegen die damals vorherrschenden, grottenschlechten Webbrowser der dritten und vierten Generation was machen.
Im Wesentlichen vor allem Netscape und Detailet Explorer.
Die beiden damals im Browserkrieg befändigt.
Alternativen gab es damals noch nie.
Ja, aber es war halt damals im Agenturalltag, war das schon so, dass wir für große Kunden eine Webseite teilweise sechsmal gebaut haben. Also für Mac IE und für Win IE und dann noch in den verschiedenen Versionen. Und dann nochmal das Ganze dann für Netscape. Nur weil die halt sehr eigenwillige Interpretationen der Webstandards hatten, was eben dazu geführt hat, dass die Kunden dann eben auch sehr viel Geld in die Hand nehmen mussten, damit es dann hinterher einigermaßen überhaupt lief und nicht dann dem Browser mitsamt Rechner in den Abgrund riss. Das kann sich heute wahrscheinlich kaum noch jemand vorstellen, dass man damals...
Aber jeder, der sich noch daran erinnern kann, erinnert sich mit Grausen.
Also wenn Netscape 4 stehen geblieben ist, dann konnte man den Mac erstmal neu starten, jedes Mal. Und dann haben wir eben dann mit so einer Horde Verrückter das Webstranded Project gegründet und versucht über sehr viel Öffentlichkeitsarbeit, aber auch über rückwärtige Kanäle zu den Browser-Entwicklern in die Entwicklungsabteilung beim Netscape und Microsoft hinein, versucht die dazu zu bewegen, mal bessere Browser in den Markt zu bringen. Und das war tatsächlich in dem Fall die Geburtsstunde von Gecko, also der Gecko-Engine, weil wir damals wirklich Netscape demonstrieren konnten, dass die mit der Engine, die sie damals am Start hatten in den Vierer-Browsern, nie und nimmer irgendeinen W3C Standard sauber verarbeiten könnten. Und da haben die dann gesagt, okay, gut, dann lass mal jetzt nochmal von vorne anfangen. Und das ist im Prinzip die Geburtsstunde von Mozilla und Firefox gewesen.
Also ich hab das nur am Rande begleitet, aber mein Eindruck aus der Ferne war, dass dieses Web-Standards-Projekt doch geschafft hat, ziemlich viel Aufhebens zu machen, innerhalb relativ kurzer Zeit. Also dieser Widerstand der Web-Designer damals, das waren vor allem die Leute, die jetzt am Implementierungsende die ganze Scheiße ausbaden mussten, das hatte doch schon eine Menge Eindruck gemacht. Das hat mich allerdings auch ein bisschen gewundert. Warum war das jetzt so effektiv?
Wir haben eine Marktlücke gefüllt. Das W3C hat damals in loser Folge sehr schnell verschiedene Standards auf den Markt geworfen, ohne dass die sauber durchgetestet und spezifiziert waren. Man muss den Browserherstellenden auch ein bisschen Nachsicht einräumen. Die konnten teilweise gar nicht anders, weil die Standards, die damals das W3C rausgebracht hat, teilweise gar nicht implementierbar waren. Das sind Altlasten, die wir bis heute mit uns herumschleppen. HTML4 ist einfach so was von unterspezifiziert, dass es wirklich an Wundergrenzen überhaupt Implementierungen davon gibt. Das ist aber trotzdem nach wie vor die Sprache, die jetzt gilt. Auch mit den Nachfolgern, mit XHTML 1.0 usw. ist ja nichts anderes als HTML4 mit noch einem Schrägstrich extra drin. Das sind halt Altlasten, die wir mit uns herumschleppen. Und das war, denke ich, die Profilsache vom Webstandards Project damals, dass wir da wirklich in die Lücke gestoßen sind, die bisher noch keiner besetzt hatte. Indem wir halt wirklich Test-Cases gebaut haben, wie damals den berühmten Asset-Test, also den allerersten Asset-Test, mit dem so Sachen, die heute selbstverständlich sind, also dass man einfach eine Box per Float neben eine andere Box stellt oder um eine andere Box herumfließen lässt und so Sachen. Und damals alle Browser einfach, ja, wahlweise Blue Screen, Core Dump oder sonst irgendwas produziert haben, also wo es wirklich bumm gemacht hat. Und die haben wir halt den Browser-Herstellern geliefert, haben gesagt, so müsste euer Browser eigentlich rendern, wenn man den Standard nimmt und den abtippt. Keiner tat es dann. Und dann sind die halt hingegangen und haben ihre Engines dann verbessert oder in jedem Fall von Mozilla eben komplett neu geschrieben.
Hat ja eine Weile gedauert mit dem Asset-Test, aber mittlerweile ist es natürlich so der heiße Scheiß. Also die letzte Version der Asset 3, da gab es ja förmlich ein Rennen der Browser-Hersteller, dann der Erste zu sein, der das irgendwie implementiert hat. Wer hat gewonnen? Gibt es einen Gewinner?
Safari, also Apple sagt Safari wäre erster gewesen, Opera sagt sie hätten aber interne Builds gehabt, die also auch vorher schon irgendwie, also Opera oder Safari eigentlich. Aber mittlerweile...
Das handelte sich dabei aber auch nur um Stunden.
Das handelte sich um Stunden. Das war wirklich, das war wirklich haarscharm.
Ja, schöner Sport. Und wie ich es richtig sehe, ist aber auch ein großer Teil dann in diese Accessibility-Geschichte auch eingeflossen.
Das hängt ganz eng zusammen. Das hängt ganz eng zusammen, dass natürlich auch sehr viele Hilfsmittel, die von Menschen mit Behinderung eingesetzt werden, darauf angewiesen sind, dass sich irgendwer bitte schön an die Standards hält. Weil auch die sind darauf angewiesen, z.B. einen sauberen Dokumentenbaum vom Browser vor die Füße geworfen zu kriegen, den sie dann sauber verarbeiten können. Wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dann kann z.B. in Screenreadern, im Blinden eben auch nichts oder im Ernstfall sogar das Falsche vorlesen, wenn das vom Browser nicht geliefert wird.
Da wo die Menschenlesbarkeit mit der Maschinenlesbarkeit zusammenhängt. Das werden wir jetzt auf jeden Fall auch gleich noch weiter vertiefen. Jetzt vielleicht noch kurz einfach für alle, das ist dein aktuelles Projekt.
Es ist ein Projekt der Aktion Mensch. Ich bin da quasi zwar Mädchen für alles, aber ich bin nur freier Mitarbeiter bei der Aktion Mensch. Ich arbeite seit fast über 10 Jahren. Da hießen die noch Aktion Sorgen Kind damals. Ich bin da so kurz vor der Namensumstellung reingerutscht und habe eine ganze Reihe Projekte für die Aktion Mensch betreut. Und im Augenblick das, was am meisten Arbeit macht und aber auch am meisten Spaß macht, ist diese Initiative einfach für alle. Die gibt es jetzt seit dem Jahr 2001. Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr.
Um den Dreh.
Webblog läuft jetzt auch schon seitdem. Wir haben einen Podcast, der zurzeit ein bisschen eingeschlafen ist. Aber Ziel der Geschichte ist eigentlich eine Auflehrungskampagne für Web-Entwickler, für Web-Designer, für Leute, die auch Auftritte bei Agenturen in Auftrag geben, sich da schlau machen zu können. Was heißt das eigentlich? Was machen Menschen mit Behinderungen im Internet? Das ist auch ein Punkt, wo wir immer noch argumentieren, ja, es gibt Menschen mit Behinderungen, die das Internet nutzen. Das schaut man manchmal in ratlose Gesichter, wenn man das so sagt. Und den Leuten eben zu erklären, was sie machen müssen, um dann hinterher von sich, von ihrem Web-Angebot behaupten zu können, ja, wir sind nach dem Stand der heutigen Technik barrierefrei.
Ja, kommen wir zum zweiten Gast hier, der sich ganz brav zurückhält. Zu meiner Rechten, Jan, was ist denn so dein Zugang zu diesem Themenbereich, wo kommst du denn her?
Ich komme von der Nutzerseite sozusagen, vor 10, 15 Jahren hatte ich also Probleme mit dem Sehen zunächst mal und das war abzusehen, dass es immer weniger wird und habe mich dann mit den Möglichkeiten des Betriebssystems erst mal beschäftigt, wie ich das für mich optimieren kann. Das hieß dann für mich persönlich, dass ich die Farben umgestellt habe, etc., damit ich nicht so geblendet werde von einem hellen Hintergrundlicht von Windows 95. Eins würde zum nächsten, irgendwann habe ich ein Buch über den Zugang zum Internet für Sehbehinderte und Blinde rezensiert und habe dann Kontakt zu einem Verlag bekommen und habe ihn gefragt, warum habt ihr das Thema Barrierefreiheit als Webdesign noch nicht behandelt. Und die haben gesagt, ja, mach. Und ich dachte, das wäre ein Scherz. Also ein paar Monate später riefen sie an, wie sieht es aus.
Und da hat sie es noch gar nicht ernst genommen.
Nee, überhaupt nichts. Und dann habe ich erst mal losgelegt und habe so 80, 90 Seiten für den Nover Verlag geschrieben. Das war 2001 dann. Und meine Sehbehinderung ist parallel immer schlechter geworden. Mittlerweile bin ich praktisch blind. Und seit 2001 habe ich mein eigenliches Interesse, als Jugendlicher war ich immer sehr computerinteressiert. Ich habe das eben zum Job gemacht. Ich habe für die Blindenverbände in Deutschland in einem Projekt mitgewirkt, wo wir unter anderem ein Testverfahren entwickelt haben, um Barrierefreiheit zu bewerten. Und seit 2005, wo ich noch ein Buch veröffentlicht habe, wo Thomas übrigens auch noch Co-Redakteur war, seit 2005 bin ich jetzt selbstständig und berate eben Organisationen, teste für die mit Screenreadern, versuche zu beurteilen, ob die Farben denn ausreichen, ob die Web-Einhalte verständlich sind etc. Und so kriegen sie dann Berichte von mir und ja, wir versuchen eben, also ich versuche von der Seite dann die Barrierefreiheit durchzusetzen. Ja genau.
Konkret zu begleiten sozusagen. Du hast ja auch immer so eine Webseite zuerstellt.
Ja genau, also das ist, also barrierefreiheitswebdesign.de habe ich ja vorhin schon gesagt, das bedarf eigentlich seit 2003 einer Überarbeitung. Das war der letzte Relaunch sozusagen.
Aber es ist nicht alles falsch, was da draufsteht?
Nein, aber einiges müsste ich auf jeden Fall überarbeiten. Und was die Standards angeht, ich meine damals war es okay. Also es gab nicht sehr viele Websites, die Standards eingehalten haben. Heute gibt es mit Sicherheit bessere Beispiele für barrierefreie Seiten. Ich nehme es mir immer wieder vor, ich habe es mir für dieses Jahr auch schon wieder vorgenommen. Mal gucken, was daraus wird.
Das heißt, du hast im Prinzip beide Seiten gehabt. Welche ich richtig verstanden habe, hast du in deiner Jugend noch 100% Sehkraft gehabt? Oder war das immer schon...
Ja, vielleicht 80%. Man weiß es nicht so ganz genau. Ich habe es ein bisschen schlechter gesehen. Ich habe damals halt einen Homecomputer gehabt mit 14, 15, 16 Jahren. Das war ein Schaub. Als es später zum Studium ging, wollte ich eigentlich Informatik studieren und mich mit diesen Themen dann auch weiter beschäftigen. Aber alle haben mir gesagt, du wirst eines Tages blind. Deswegen kannst du nicht am Computer arbeiten. Und deswegen habe ich BWL studiert. Hat aber auch nicht geschadet.
BWL zu studieren hat nicht geschadet? Oder das Blindsein hat nicht geschadet?
Nein, ich meinte jetzt eigentlich das Studium. Man lernt vieles fürs Leben. Für mich war das immer ein bisschen Allgemeinwissen fürs Leben. Also strukturiertes Allgemeinwissen.
Würdest du das unterschreiben, dass man nicht Informatik studieren soll, nur weil man blind ist?
Das ist doch auch Quatsch, oder? Heute ist es selbstverständlich. Es gibt sehr viele Blinde, die programmieren. Das ist ihr Job, sie studieren das, sie verdienen ihr Geld damit. Heute ist es ja mit Screenreadern, die deutlich weiterentwickelt sind als vor 25 Jahren, überhaupt kein Problem, mit dem Computer umzugehen. Es gibt natürlich ein paar Besonderheiten, gar keine Frage, aber an Informationen kommt man immer. Und an einer Konsole sowieso, also Programmieren, ist durchaus ein blinden Beruf.
Ja, und das sehe ich ja eigentlich auch genau. Programmieren, das findet ja im Wesentlichen auch im Kopf statt und nicht so sehr auf dem Bildschirm eigentlich. Also das ist meine Erfahrung, dass man...
Also...
Es gibt natürlich einen Moment der Umsetzung, aber...
Ja, also die Funktion usw., das findet tatsächlich erst mal im Kopf statt und man muss es dann irgendwie runterschreiben. Wenn wir über Webentwicklung sprechen, spielt Design natürlich auch eine wichtige Rolle. Nicht nur beim Webdesign, aber Design spielt immer wieder eine Rolle. Und da schaut der Blinde meistens zur Tiefe. Bei dieser visuellen Darbietung der Information, die ist sehr schwer nachzuvollziehen mit einer Schwachausgabe.
Ja, wie sieht es denn jetzt aus? Also ich meine, wir hatten vorhin auch schon mal so angerissen, so dieser Begriff selber ist ein bisschen umstritten oder wie? Ich meine so Accessibility, ist das jetzt so der richtige Begriff? Ich meine, auf Deutsch sagt man jetzt Barrierefreiheit, ist das dasselbe?
Trifst das?
Vielleicht soll ich mal anfangen, dann kannst du Kontra geben oder sollen wir es umgekehrt machen? Ich kann ja mal anfangen. Also Barrierefreiheit ist ein gesetzlich definierter Begriff und umfasst auf Deutsch zumindest die Zugänglichkeit und die Nutzbarkeit für Menschen mit Behinderungen. Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir den Begriff Accessibility. Das ist eigentlich eine direkte Übersetzung, wird auch sehr oft benutzt in Deutschland für die Barrierefreiheit. Wenn man das übersetzt, ist es aber meistens nur Zugänglichkeit. Und die Zugänglichkeit ist sicher technisch geprägt. Das heißt, wenn man Standards einhält, sind die Inhalte meistens auch zugänglich. Aber weil die Barrierefreiheit eben diese Nutzbarkeit mit umfasst, kommen wir da in ein Gebiet, wo man mit Technik nicht viel weiterkommt.
Wo hört die Zugänglichkeit auf und wo beginnt das mit der Nutzbarkeit? Von was für Übergängen reden wir da?
Zum Beispiel, wenn eine Seite mit Überschriften und Listen gegliedert ist, sind die einzelnen Informationen strukturiert und man kommt irgendwie an diese Informationen ran. Aber wie arbeitet jetzt ein blinder Nutzer, der auf diese Überschriften und Listen möglicherweise angewiesen ist? Also man kann zum Beispiel von Überschrift zu Überschrift springen. Sind da vielleicht zu viele Überschriften auf einer Seite, bevor man zum Inhalt kommt? Oder ist es umgekehrt, sind zu wenige Überschriften, zu wenig Listen, zu wenig Frukturen insgesamt, damit dieser Nutzer tatsächlich die Information auswerten kann? Er hat ja nicht das Layout, er hat ja nur diese Strukturmerkmale, der blinde Nutze, sag ich mal. Und eine scharfe Grenze gibt es da nicht.
Man muss immer beobachten.
Und das hängt vom Angebot selbst ab.
Also es gibt eine ganze Reihe an Kriterien, die wirklich die reine technische Barrierefreiheit betreffen. Das sind aber, also wenn man jetzt mal von der zurzeit gültigen Bundesverordnung ausgeht, wo, korrigiere ich, 63 Punkte drin sind.
66.
66, glaube ich, sind davon 7, allerhöchstens 9 von den 66 überhaupt wirklich diese ganz harten technischen Barrieren, die dann auch maschinentestbar sind. Also wo man mit einem geeigneten Programm prüfen kann, ist das erfüllt oder nicht. Und der Rest geht dann schon sehr schnell in Richtung einer ganz spezifischen Usability für Menschen mit Behinderung und ihre ganz speziellen Nutzungsszenarien. Also mit welchen Geräten gehen die da dran. Oder wenn die Barriere für den Nutzer eben nicht eine technische Barriere ist, eine inhaltliche Barriere, wo ist da die Schwelle ab, wo Sachen verstanden oder nicht mehr verstanden werden und solche Geschichten. Da ist man sehr schnell im Bereich einer ganz speziellen Usability für typische Szenarien.
Dabei ist es nicht der eine Nutzer. Also wenn ich das zum Beispiel der Sehbehinderten sagen darf, es gibt wirklich hunderte von Sehbehinderungen. Und auch sehr viele individuelle Wahrnehmungen der eigenen Behinderung. Was für den einen Sehbehinderten gut sein kann, ist für den nächsten vielleicht schlecht. Und mit einem ganz konkreten Beispiel, wenn man jetzt Farben auf einer Website benutzt, spielt Kontrast natürlich eine Rolle für Sehbehinderte, für manche Sehbehinderte, nicht für alle. Aber auch die Schriftart und vieles andere mehr. Und auch Schriftgröße. Ich habe das einmal erlebt, dass ich eine etwas extravagante Schriftart einfach mal eingesetzt habe. Experimentell. Und habe dann noch eine Runde von Sehbehinderten gefragt, wie sieht es aus? Und eine sagte, der Kontrast wäre zu gering. Das konnte ich irgendwie verstehen. Es war aber nicht der Kontrast, weil es war schwarz auf weiß. Also viel mehr geht nicht. Es war die Schriftart. Und da wird das Problem...
Was für eine Schriftart war das?
Irgendetwas Schnörkliges. Und es war auch sehr klein. Und diese Dinge, die sind ganz schwer zu fassen dann auch.
Gibt es denn spezielle Schriftarten auch für sowas?
Es gibt Schriftarten, wo die Anbieter von der Schriftart behaupten, sie seien für Sehbehinderte optimiert.
Es gibt jede Menge Empfehlungen im Netz, was man nehmen sollte, bis hin zu Comic Sans und anderen Abstrositäten.
Die man nehmen soll oder nicht nehmen soll?
Es gibt tatsächlich Untersuchungen, ob die jetzt wirklich seriös sind, weiß ich nicht, dass für Menschen mit bestimmten kognitiven Behinderungen die Comic Sans am besten zu lesen ist. Das ist so eine Empfehlung, die ist sowas von unargumentierbar einem Kunden gegenüber. Damit macht man sich eigentlich nur lächerlich, wenn man damit nach Forderungen hinkommt und sagt, du musst aber jetzt diese Schrift nehmen. Nein, Jan spricht da einen ganz wichtigen Punkt an. Es gibt gerade im Bereich der Typografie, und das meiste Webdesign ist ja in irgendeiner Form Typografie, bis zu einer wirklich guten Lesetypografie, gibt es keine Maße oder bestimmte Farbschema da, die man benutzen sollte oder nicht benutzen darf oder ähnliches. Und auch das, was man immer wieder im Netz liest, Sehbehinderte brauchen große Schrift, das ist auch grober Unfug, weil sie brauchen skalierbare Schrift. Ein Sehbehindert muss die Schrift an seine Bedürfnisse anpassen können. Aber eine Schrift, die mindestens 16 oder 24 Punkten groß ist, nützt natürlich jemanden, der einen Tunnelblick hat und dann von der Schrift nur noch die Unterlänge sieht. Das ist natürlich herzlich wenig. Die Schrift muss so angelegt sein, dass er die Schrift auf seine speziellen Bedürfnisse anpassen kann. Das ist eine Forderung, die kann man stellen. Das Gleiche mit Farbschema-Tages. Das fängt mit Sehbehindern, mit Farbfehlsichtigkeiten an. Jeder siebte, achte Mann auf diesem Planeten ist farbfehlsichtig. Das sitzt dummerweise auf dem Y. Da sind jetzt nur wir von betroffen. Und es gibt ganz wenige.
Was war der Prozentsatz, den du gerade genannt hast?
Jeder siebte, achte ungefähr.
Die Zahlen schwanken, manche heißen 10%.
Also 10-20%?
Nein, 20% nicht.
7-10%. Wir haben irgendeine Form der Farbfehlsichtigkeit, aber es gibt eben verschiedene Formen der Farbfehlsichtigkeit, die sich teilweise eben auch ausschließen.
Meistens ist es, glaube ich, rot-grün-Blindheit?
Das ist das Häufigste in der Tat. Da gibt es aber noch mindestens zwei andere Farbfehlsichtigkeitsformen. Und es gibt auch noch, und die sind aber ganz selten, das sind dann wirklich die Farben, die blind sind, die wirklich nur Graustufen sehen. Das ist aber extrem selten. Aber innerhalb dieser normalen Farbfehlsichtigkeiten gibt es eben auch welche, die bestimmte Farben sehr hell wahrnehmen. Und andere nehmen diese Farben sehr dunkel wahr. Sodass man dann nicht sagen kann, du musst jetzt die Farbe auf dem Hintergrund funktionieren für den, aber für den anderen. Verstehe. Also auch da wieder, man darf eben Sachen nicht nur über Farbe transportieren. Wenn Farbe alleiniges Unterscheidungsmerkmal oder Gestaltungsmerkmal ist, also mein Lieblingsbeispiel ist immer so ein Pie-Chart, da muss noch irgendwas anderes rein. Muster, eine Schraffur oder sonst irgendwas, das ist differenzierbar. Am besten mit einer Legende, wo da nicht steht, rot ist der Wert, grün ist der Wert, blau ist der Wert, sondern eben rot und schraffiert und blau und schräg gestrichelt. Sprich, wenn ich so einen Graustufenausdrucker auf dem Laser drucke, dass ich es dann auch noch erkennen kann.
Da kommt mir jetzt gerade so eine blöde Idee, ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie schon mal diskutiert wurde. Wenn ich jetzt Fehlfarben habe auf meinem Computer, man kennt das ja im Prinzip schon in dem Moment, wo ich einen Rechner an meinem Projektor anschließe, da kommt halt irgendwas raus und dann kann ich da eben eine Farbkalibration vornehmen. Es gibt ja auch so Ideen, dass man sozusagen das Benutzerprofil, diese Fehlsichtigkeit klassifiziert und dann quasi so als Profil im Browser hat, so dass die Webseite sich darauf dann auch einstellen kann. Also gibt es Systematik?
Ist das ein Style-Switcher jetzt oder was?
Bitte?
Meinst du einen Style-Switcher oder meinst du...
Nee, dass man also wirklich, dass jetzt mal nicht nur die Webseite maschinenlesbar ist, sondern auch die Anforderungen des Benutzers, dass man sozusagen seine Sicht-Einschränkungen auch konkret mal in XML formuliert und sagt irgendwie, ich halte jetzt Bedarf an sowas, dass ich da eine Webseite ran... Ist das jetzt nur so ein Gedanke, der mir gerade kommt?
Nee, das System funktioniert anders. Also es gibt bestimmte Kriterien, die ich sage mal von der Webentwicklung zu leisten wären. Also dafür gibt es ja die Web Content Accessibility Guidelines. Und es gibt andere Anforderungen, die zum Beispiel von den User-Agents, also zum Beispiel Browser, ebenfalls erfüllt sein müssen. Und unter anderem zählt dazu, dass der Browser dem Nutzer die Möglichkeit geben muss, Farben zu überschreiben.
Zu überschreiben, also zu ersetzen.
Ah ja, zu ersetzen.
Also durch eigene Style-Checks.
Ja, also das betrifft auch die Schriftart und Schriftgröße. Aber ich kann in einem beliebigen Browser mittlerweile sagen, ich möchte, weil ich habe es da vorhin schon erwähnt, weil ich geblendet werde und viele Seiten haben einen weißen Hintergrund, dann sage ich, okay, dann will ich einen dunklen Hintergrund, meinetwegen schwarz, und wähle natürlich einen Text weiß, die links, meinetwegen gelb. Und somit würde jede Seite so angezeigt werden. Alle Farben werden dadurch ignoriert, bis auf die Farben von Grafiken.
Das Design ist aber teilweise schon sehr komplex heute, wo sind wir uns, glaube ich, mit dem Austausch von zwei, drei Farben nicht unbedingt...
Wird nicht reichen, nein. Und das löst auch das Problem des Nutzers nicht, weil der Nutzer hat das Problem ja nicht nur im Browser, sondern er hat das ja im Computer generell. Das heißt, es ist eigentlich eine Aufgabe des Betriebssystems und das machen die Betriebssysteme auch. Ich von der Mac OS X kann ich den Bildschirm mit einem Tastendruck invertieren, habe dann quasi eine negative Darstellung. Und so was Ähnliches gibt es unter Windows auch. Da gibt es sogar verschiedene Kontrastschematar. Da gibt es dann irgendwie gelben Text auf schwarzem Hintergrund und gelber Text auf Querbiet mit extra großen Buchstaben und so weiter, weil es nichts nützen würde, wenn Webseiten das alle einzeln anbieten. Und jeder einzelne Web-Anbieter müsste das irgendwie bereitstellen und implementieren und irren Aufwand machen. Sondern das ist tatsächlich etwas, weil der Benutzer das ja nicht nur im Browserfenster hat, sondern generell bei der Nutzung seines Computers. Also es ist eigentlich seine Aufgabe, den Computer generell auf Betriebssystem-Ebene schon so einzustellen, dass ihm, wenn er eben blendet, empfindlich ist, die Blendung gemindert wird, indem invertierte Farben benutzt werden und so weiter. Was Aufgabe des Anbieters ist, ist zu testen, funktioniert meine Webseite noch, wenn jetzt jemand mit meinem, meine Seite betrachtet und hat so ein Windows-Kontrast-Schema da. Also ein ganz klassisches Beispiel, was immer wieder schief geht, ganz typischer Fehler ist, egal ob es ein GIF oder ein PING ist. Also wenn ich eine schwarze Form oder eine schwarze Grafik oder schwarzen Text freigestellt auf weißem Hintergrund habe. Und die ist jetzt entweder mit einem Alpha-Kanal oder wie beim GIF mit einer Nagelschere irgendwie ausgeschnitten, freigestellt und der Benutzer kommt dann auf einmal mit invertierten Farben daher, also mit schwarzem Hintergrund und auf dem wird meine schwarze Grafik dargestellt. Dann ist die Info weg. Dann ist es für den Nutzer, der zwar noch sieht, aber eben schon so schlecht sieht oder so eine Sehbehinderung hat, dass er eben irgendwas an seinem Computer geschraubt hat, ist die Information dann nicht mehr wahrnehmbar. So ein ganz typischer Fehler.
Ja, vielleicht sind wir mal auch grundsätzlich noch mal so auf diese Frage der Einschränkungen, soweit eine Sehbehinderte, haben wir jetzt schon mal so angesprochen, aber die ganze Barrierefreiheitsdiskussion bezieht sich ja jetzt nicht nur auf Sehbehinderung. Mit was für Kategorien von Behinderungen sollte man jetzt eigentlich rechnen, wenn man jetzt so eine Webseite der Öffentlichkeit anbietet, und es ist jetzt auch wirklich mal die breite Masse Behörden oder so, die halt einfach mal die ganze Bevölkerung ansprechen müssen. Was für Behinderungen kommen sozusagen zum Zuge, auch in diesen ganzen Standards? Was muss man überhaupt wissen?
Ja, Sehbehinderungen hatten wir.
Das ist ja so der Klassiker, sag ich mal.
Der Klassiker, also als Merksatz wirklich.
Obwohl der Klassiker ist eigentlich die Blindheit. Die Sehbehinderungen werden auch oft vergessen.
Aber absolute Blindheit betrifft natürlich auch viele. Leute. Aber auch in Relationen relativ wenige. Also sehr viele Blinde haben natürlich auch noch, die sind zwar vor dem Gesetz blind, aber trotzdem noch ein Sehrest, den sie in irgendeiner Form nutzen können, aber eben nicht wirklich produktiv nutzen können, aber sie ihn trotzdem noch nutzen, unter Umständen. Ja, klar, natürlich. Und das ist auch ganz typisch für Sehbehinderungen. Und die meisten Sehbehinderungen sind eben degenerativ, indem sie in irgendeiner Form dann mal zur Blindheit führen. Es ist ganz typisch für Sehbehinderte, dass die sich an diesen Sehrest klammern und den natürlich so lange wie möglich noch irgendwie nutzen wollen. Also die orientieren sich nach wie vor an der grafischen Gestaltung einer Webseite. Das auf jeden Fall. Bei Blinden wiederum, wie gesagt, also absolut geburtsblinden Menschen, da ist die Gestaltung egal. Da ist die Struktur wichtig. Das hatte der Jan eben schon schön ausgeführt, dass da eben wirklich ein semantisches Mark abverwendet wird mit Überschriften und die Absätze und Listen und alles. Als solche ausgezeichnet, da wo es hingehört. Aber das ist, wie gesagt, in dem Fall, das sind technische Barrieren, die man mit technischen Mitteln lösen.
Da ist dann sozusagen die Accessibility ist die Usability. Also so gut wie es zugänglich ist, so gut es ist dann auch nutzbar.
Aber dann kommen noch ein paar andere Gruppen dazu. Also es gibt Leute, die grundsätzlich mit der Maus nicht arbeiten können oder auch nicht mit der Tastatur, weil sie motorische Einschränkungen haben. Und da gibt es auch sehr viele verschiedene Einschränkungen. Die einen können ihre Hände nur grob bewegen. Die haben dann so eine Riesentastatur mit Riesentasten, damit sie die auch besser treffen können. Und die anderen, die versuchen die Maus hin und her zu schieben, da gibt es dann vielleicht eine Bildschirm-Tastatur dazu, um eben auch einzutippen, weil sie einen sehr eingeschränkten Radius haben. Für den Web-Entwickler ist das meistens ein relatives Problem, weil die Hilfsmittel, die da eingesetzt werden, also der Maus meistens oder eben der Tastatur entsprechen. Es gibt aber natürlich noch Spracheingabe für Leute, die ihre Arme überhaupt nicht bewegen können. Auch da haben wir dann so eine Spracherkennung, wie Dragon Naturally Speaking oder sowas. Aber damit wird eben auch eine Maus oder eine Tastatur bedient. Wichtig bei der ganzen Geschichte, und das betrifft im Übrigen Blinde auch, ist, dass viele Leute mit der Maus einfach nicht arbeiten und ausschließlich mit der Tastatur navigieren müssen. Man kennt das vielleicht mit der Tab-Taste, aber es gibt auch andere Möglichkeiten, durch eine Seite zu navigieren. Und da wieder dieser semantische Seitenaufbau. Wenn eine Seite semantisch aufgebaut ist, also mit Überschriften, Listen etc., gibt es zum Beispiel einen Browser Opera, aber auch andere Anwendungen, mit denen man diese Elemente auch anspringen kann, von Überschrift zu Überschrift beispielsweise. Das ist mehr so die technische Ecke, also blinden Sehbehinderten und Automatomschränkchen.
Das ist übrigens auch meine Anforderung. Ich habe auch schon immer ein großes Interesse daran gehabt, die Maus nicht benutzen zu müssen. Ich stelle mir auch jedes neue Setup immer sofort auf maximale Tastatur-Steuerbarkeit ein. Aber dass eben nicht alles erreichbar ist, das wohnt mich auch sehr.
Auch da gibt es natürlich Unterschiede. Man hat gerade schon im Opera angesprochen, das ist ein sehr guter Browser für Tastatur-Nutzer. Der wird nur dummerweise von den Screenreadern nicht unterstützt.
Aber die Screenreader haben eigene Funktionen.
Ja, die haben eigene Funktionen dafür.
Screenreader sollte man vielleicht kurz erklären. Screenreader ist Software, die man sich auf seinem Rechner installiert, wenn sie nicht schon mit dem Betriebssystem daherkommt, die einem im Prinzip den Inhalt des Bildschirms erschließt. Kann man das so sagen?
Das ist die GUI des Blinden.
Die GUI des Blinden.
Also dahinter steckt eine riesengroße Datenbank, um das Betriebssystem plus Anwendungen zu bedienen.
Es gibt Unterschiede. Es gibt Betriebssystem Welten. Die meisten Unix, Linux und Mac OS kommen, sobald man den Karton aufmacht, mit einem Screenreader dabei. Der ist damit drauf. Der ist ganz tief unten im Betriebssystem, hart quadratet drin. Der weltmeist verbreitetste Screenreader ist VoiceOver für Mac OS X, weil er mit dabei ist. Da kann man sich gar nicht gegen wehren. Es gibt unter Windows diesen komischen Narrator, dieses Vorleseprogrammchen. Das ist eigentlich eher ein schlechter Scherz und für Blinde gar nicht geeignet. Das ist mal nett, um sich ein paar Sachen vorlesen zu lassen. Der bietet nicht den Zugang zum Betriebssystem und allen Anwendungen wie ein richtig echter Screenreader, die unter Windows üblicherweise aufgedeckelt werden. Also irgendwas, was hinterher dann dran getackert wird. Und dann unter Umständen mehr schlecht als recht funktioniert. Also da merkt man unter Windows sehr deutlich, dass die erst im Nachhinein dann so drangeflanscht wurden und versuchen dann das Betriebssystem quasi von oben und nicht von unten zu gehen.
Weil die nicht die richtigen Hooks haben dafür.
Es funktioniert auch nicht mit allen Anwendungen.
Ja, das ist das Problem.
Also mit Microsoft-Anwendungen funktioniert es meistens gut. Aber kommt ein neuer Browser, also wie Opera zum Beispiel, das ist auch nicht neu, aber kommt eine andere Anwendung daher, dann kriegt man nur die Hälfte mit.
Also die Betriebssysteme, die haben sogenannte Accessibility APIs, das sind einfach Schnittstellen, über die Hilfsmittel mit Informationen versorgt werden. Das ist unter Windows lange Zeit die MSAA gewesen. Oder naja, mit Vista sollte dann eine neue Schnittstelle rauskommen. Da haben aber alle Hilfsmittel-Hersteller dann quasi bei Microsoft Einspruch eingelegt, weil sie zu viel in die alte Schnittstelle schon investiert hatten, die wollten dann keine neue haben. Also gibt es nach wie vor diese MSAA, also Microsoft...
Die Hersteller von Software für Vereinfachungen haben sich gegen eine Vereinfachung gewährt.
Interessant.
Es gibt aber eben unter Linux und Mac OS X vergleichbare Schnittstellen. Das sind einfach Programmierschnittstellen, die man als Programmierer eben benutzen kann. Aber es zwingt einen leider keiner dazu.
Dann können wir es noch mal kurz benennen. Was sind denn die populären Systeme unter Windows, die so eingesetzt werden?
Marktführer JAWS in Deutschland.
In Deutschland auf jeden Fall. 60% plus.
JAWS ist JAWS.
JAWS, also wie der Weiße Hai. Haben die ja auf dem Logo drauf. Ist sicher weltweit der Marktführer in Deutschland.
In den USA teilt sich das so sehr viel auf zwischen JAWS und Window Eyes. Aber Window Eyes ist in Deutschland noch nicht... Window Eyes ist in Deutschland noch nicht wirklich verbreitet. In Deutschland gibt es zwei deutsche Produkte, die sehr häufig eingesetzt werden. Das sind Blindos, auch ein lustiger Name.
Den hätte Microsoft auch nehmen können.
Und Blindos und Virgo gehören beide mittlerweile einer Firma, Ferner Baum.
Und dann einen Nachfolger jetzt. Da gibt es auch einen neuen, Cobra. Ja, das ist der Nachfolger. Beide Produkte quasi zusammengeführt. Und das ist so der deutsche Screenreader eigentlich, der auch noch sehr verbreitet ist.
Man muss bei Blindos und Virgo aber sagen, die Arbeit nicht nativ mit dem Browser zusammen. Es gehört noch eine Brücken-Software dazwischen. Und das ist der Webformat. Und den gibt es kostenlos. Da kann jeder das herunterladen, webformato.de. Und damit sieht man auch, wie ein Blinder, also die Information, die ein Blinder bekommt. Allerdings muss man sagen, JAWS und Window Eyes ziehen wesentlich mehr Information aus einer Seite drauf.
Das komische ist bei den Windows-Screenreadern, die haben eine Mischform aus dem Anzapfen der Accessibility API und eigenen Methoden, die aber eben mehr proprietär sind und nicht verraten werden, wie sie es machen. Und man kann dann nur durch Beobachten feststellen, was der Screenreader gerade da veranstaltet hat. Offscreen Modeling. Ja, da gibt es die folgenden Geschichten. Es gibt aber ein paar schöne Test-Tools, die man quasi in die Schnittstelle reinklemmen kann. Und dann sieht man, tickert das quasi mit, wird dann ausgegeben, was gerade über die Schnittstelle rauskommt. Und dann kann man das abgleichen mit dem, was aus dem Lautsprecher kommt. Das ist auch nicht immer identisch. Also es ist nicht ganz unproblematisch, das Modell, wie es unter Windows funktioniert. Und ich bin eigentlich eher ein großer Freund davon, von der Art und Weise, wie andere Betriebssysteme damit umgeben, indem einfach das Vorlesen von Bildschirminhalten gleichwertig behandelt wird, wie die Versorgung der Grafikkarte und des Monitors. Das ist einfach das Betriebssystem.
So läuft es auf Mac und so läuft es bei Linux.
Wobei, ich meine, es gibt ja immer Einschränkungen. Also VoiceOver ist auch nicht der perfekte Screenreader.
Nein, nein, der ist maximal Version 1.1.
Also der hängt ein bisschen hinterher, gegenüber den kommerziellen Produkten für Linux.
Obwohl der Ansatz sozusagen, also der Ansatz ist eigentlich besser, aber müsste eigentlich noch mehr hinein. Was fehlt da jetzt? Was kann man da rausziehen?
Also ich bin kein Mac-Nutzer. Man kann zum Beispiel Sachen lesen, ein Dokument zum Beispiel oder bestimmte Schalter, aber man ist nicht frei, also man kann nicht alles lesen. Würdest du das so bestätigen? Du hast ja einen Mac.
Jetzt bin ich nicht so der typisch blinde User, aber ich kann es halt eben auch nur als Erfahrungsberichtung von tatsächlich blinden Mac-Usern wiedergeben. Also Marco zum Beispiel, der auch umgestiegen ist und damit offensichtlich ganz gut zufrieden ist.
Gut, den werde ich mal interviewen.
Es gibt auch eine Website dazu, die schreibe ich mal in die Show Notes rein. Die heißt Blind Switchers Group oder so etwas. Ich weiß nicht, ich muss ich mal nach suchen. Ich wollte es gerade sagen. Da gibt es auch eine eigene Community. Also es tut es schon. Es gibt aber unter Linux halt ein paar sehr schöne Entwicklungen. Also NVDA und Orca sind richtig klasse. Und mittlerweile auch, kann man, denke ich, ruhigen Wissens behaupten, mit den großen kommerziellen Paketen durchaus vergleichbar im Leistungsumfang.
Ja, also ich habe beides schon mal im Test gehabt. NVDA läuft auch auf Windows. Es ist okay. Aber auch hier, was das Web angeht, im Leistungsumfang deutlich hinter beispielsweise Java.
Es sind ja auch komplexe Produkte. Man darf sich das nicht vorstellen wie ein einfaches Vorleseprogrammchen, wo man dann wie ein Flash-Media-Player auf Play und Pause drücken kann, sondern es sind wirklich so komplexe Produkte, dass die mehr Tastaturshortcuts zur Verfügung stellen, als es Tasten auf der Tastatur gibt. Also vier Tasten auf einmal, das ist nichts für mich. Das ist für einen blinden User komplett normal, in dauernd vier Tasten gedrückt zu haben und irgendwas damit zu machen. Und die sich auch noch alle zu merken. Weil man kann ja nicht nachlesen, wie die jetzt gerade sind. Sondern die muss man alle auswendig lernen. Das sind schon extrem komplexe Produkte.
Ja, also ich sehe schon, wir sind jetzt schon wieder mit den Screenreadern dabei. Sehbehinderung ist eigentlich schon, sagen wir mal, der größte Hauptproblemanteil, kann man sagen.
Es ist das Greifbarsteln.
Es ist so herrlich, einfach demonstrierbar.
Verstehe, und alles andere ist auch einfach sehr vielfältig.
Ja, also man kann natürlich Blindheit und auch bis zu einem gewissen Gras, gerade Sehbehinderung, kann man simulieren. Gehörlosigkeit kann man nicht simulieren, also wir können weggucken, aber wir können nicht weghören als Mensch.
Und da entstehen ganz andere Probleme auch. Also es gibt ja zwei Gruppen, sage ich mal, von Behinderten, wobei ich eigentlich gegen diese Klassifizierung bin, aber es gibt zwei Einschränkungen, die wir bis jetzt noch nicht behandelt haben. Das ist einmal Gehörlosigkeit und natürlich auch Lernbehinderung. Und beides geht in den Bereich Verständlichkeit. Was viele Leute zum Beispiel nicht wissen, ist, dass manche Gehörlose so eine Muttersprache haben, die nicht Deutsch ist, sondern eben die deutsche Gebärdensprache. Und da ist Deutsch, also die deutsche Sprache, die wir jetzt gerade sprechen.
Die erste Fremdsprache, ja.
Und da kommen ganz andere Forderungen daher, wie mit Inhalten umzugehen ist, also sprich Gebärdensprachfilme. Und bei Lernbehindernungen haben wir ein ähnlich komplexes Thema und leider auch wenig erforscht. Also es gibt immer wieder Meldungen dazu, was man alles betrugsichtigen könnte. Also beim Beano Award beispielsweise sind die ganzen oder einige Texte auch in einfacher Sprache formuliert. Aber das ist quasi eine Übersetzung, also wie in der Englischsprache gesagt.
Das ist eine eigenschönliche Sprachversion noch mit Umschalten.
Gibt es eigentlich eine Wikipedia in Gebärdensprache?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Ist das überhaupt realisierbar?
Aber es gibt einen Wiki für leichte Sprache.
Gibt es denn eine Schreibform für Gebärdensprache? Also gibt es überhaupt die Möglichkeit, textuell Gebärdensprache auszudrücken?
Nein. Es gibt eine Kombination aus Gestik, Mimik, Bewegung. Das lässt sich nicht auf Papier bringen, weil natürlich die Bewegung auch eine Rolle spielt. Man hat ja nicht die Gebärde, die auf dem Foto darstellbar ist, sondern man hat in der Gebärdensprache einen sogenannten Gebärdenraum. Das ist wirklich ein Würfel um den Sprecher, wie beim Baseball, wo man hinwerfen darf. Da muss man sich das vorstellen. Dieses Quadrat ist das. Da drin bewegt sich der Sprecher, der Gebärdende, und bewegt alles an den Körperteilen, was in diesem Raum gerade drin ist. Auch die Position der Arme zum Körper und zum Kopf haben da irgendwo eine Bedeutung. Das lässt sich nicht...
Aber das könnte man auch konkret beschreiben. Gibt es nicht Gebärdensprachroboter?
Ja, da gibt es Avatar. Da gibt es von der Uni Hamburg ein großes Forschungsprojekt. Die sind auch schon relativ weit. Die bauen einen Avatar, der in Gebärdensprache richtig in 3D sprechen kann.
Aber den müsste man dann auch mit Gebärdensprache füllen und nicht mit Deutsch.
Den kann man nicht mit Deutsch füllen. Das ist eine eigene Sprache.
Deswegen frage ich mich jetzt gerade, dann muss es ja auch eine Schriftform geben oder zumindest irgendeine maschinelle Speicherform.
Das ist die Behinderung. Die Schiffsprachenkompetenz ist bei manchen vermindert. Entschuldigung. Deswegen abstrahiert man ja von der Schrift. Diese andere Sprache stützt sich auf G-Stick-Mimik.
Man kann mit ihr trotzdem komplexe Sachverhalte darstellen. Das ist keine Vereinfachung.
Kann man das irgendwie akustisch machen?
Das ist mit Podcasts jetzt ein bisschen schwierig.
Was wird denn gesagt in einer Gebärde? Was für Begriffe werden denn da... Ich will das jetzt nicht zu sehr vertiefen, aber es interessiert mich jetzt einfach gerade.
Es ist teilweise eine sehr plastische Sprache. Ein ganz, ganz einfaches Beispiel ist Browser.
Jetzt hast du so eine Bewegung gemacht, die keiner gesehen hat.
Ich habe eine Bewegung gemacht, die aussieht, als würde ich jetzt ein Browserfenster runterscrollen mit der Hand. Also als hättest du dich jetzt am Mac auf einem großen Trackpad und würdest dann mit diesem Fingergeste...
Mit zwei Fingern einfach von oben nach unten ziehen.
Und dann würdest du von oben nach unten ziehen. Das ist dann Browser.
Also die Geste war jetzt so, als würde man so ein Laternen-File packen und kurz nach unten rutschen.
Meine Kinder haben mir mal dieselbe Frage gestellt. Die Gebärde, bei denen hängen geblieben ist, glaube ich, die sind da.
Das ist irgendwie...
Scheiße.
Das war auch das schlechteste Wort, was ich im Funktionsstudio gelernt habe.
Wie beschreibt man das jetzt? Daumen ausgesteckt und die andere Hand fast um den Daumen und der Daumen rutscht so nach unten raus. Also das ist...
Sehr plastisch.
Also das ist teilweise wirklich eine sehr schöne Sprache. Es macht auch Spaß, mit Gebärden Dolmetscher vorzuzugucken, obwohl man sie nicht versteht. Das ist schon etwas ganz, ganz, ganz ästhetisches. Das ist ein anmutiges Teilreise. Aber auch sehr bildlich. Die haben aber auch das Problem, dass sie immer ein bisschen hinterherhinken. Also auch die haben natürlich so Neologismen wie Brauser zum Beispiel. Da müssen sich die Gebärdensprachnutzer weltweit erstmal auf eine gemeinsame Gebärde einigen.
Tun die das mittlerweile weltweit?
Das tun die mittlerweile. Da haben die einen echten Vorteil, weil jemand, der deutsche Gebärdensprache sehr gut beherrscht, der wird mit ganz minimaler Einarbeitungszeit sich dann mit einem amerikanischen Gehörlosen unterhalten können. Das American Sign Language ist nicht das Gleiche wie die deutsche Gebärdensprache, aber sie sind zumindest so ähnlich, dass die sehr schnell miteinander kommunizieren können.
Das heißt, ein Gebärdensprach-Esperanto ist eigentlich noch eher greifbar als...
Im Prinzip ja. Aber auch da gibt es Dialekte. Also ein norddeutscher Gehörloser gebärdet anders als ein süddeutscher Gehörloser. Die haben also da auch ihre eigenen Dialekte teilweise.
Aber solche Gebärden, die werden tatsächlich im laufenden Band erfunden. Da fällt mir nämlich gerade ein, ich habe letztens für eine Freundin, die zufällig auch Gebärdensprachdol-Macherin ist, eine kleine Website gemacht. Das heißt jetzt einfach mal Sichtzeichen. Sie wollte das gebärdet haben, einfach um etwas zu transportieren.
Sichtzeichen.
Ja, und da hat sie was gemacht. Da ist es fotografiert. Und das ist jetzt die neue Gebärde für Sichtzeichen.
Jetzt einfach definiert sozusagen.
Genau, also muss man einfach draufgucken. Die Hände sind, also ich kann es ja selbst nicht sehen. Ihr könnt es ja gar nicht beschreiben. Ich hatte ein Alternativtext dafür geschrieben.
Es dreht sich hier alles im Kreis. Ja, vielleicht zwei Sachen wollte ich nochmal aufgreifen. Du hast gerade so gesagt, es ist noch wenig erforscht. Wer forscht denn überhaupt? Wird denn überhaupt geforscht?
Ja, es gibt einzelne Projekte. Solche Projekte werden immer wieder gefördert. Auch im Bereich Behinderung natürlich. Action Mensch ist ja auch an solchen Projekten immer wieder beteiligt. Ich schaue meistens nach den USA, weil die sind da ein Stückchen weiter. Jetzt fällt mir gerade die Seite nicht ein, sonst muss sie nachher nochmal nachreichen. Aber die haben auch ganz schön mitgemischt beim WCAG. Die Wisconsin University, die haben relativ viel zu dem Thema. Es ist natürlich schwierig, weil man verlangt von der Webentwicklung, von den Webanbietern, dass sie ganz schön viel anpassen. Viele Leute werden ihre Webseiten aus journalistischer Sicht vielleicht aufbauen. Es sollen Informationen da rein, die sollen eine bestimmte Qualität haben. Diese Qualität definiert man ja irgendwie selbst aus seiner Ausbildung etc. Jetzt kommen Anfragen der Barrierefreiheit, die sagen, die Texte müssen einfacher sein, die Navigation muss viel simpler sein. Wir brauchen Symbole zum Beispiel, um Leute, die keine schriftsprachigen Kompetenz haben, auch bei der Navigation zu unterstützen. Da fällt mir jetzt auch ein kleines Projekt, wo ich einfach reingeschnuppert bin. Da ging es um das Bloggen, Barrierefreiheit, für Menschen mit Behinderungen. Einige Teilnehmer hatten eine kognitive Einschränkung. Der eine konnte zum Beispiel nicht lesen, aber trotzdem ist er immer surfen gegangen. Ich habe mich gefragt, wie er das macht. Den Computer bedient hat er mit einer Spracheingabe. Und gelesen wurde mit einer Sprachausgabe. Um seine Seiten zu finden, hat er immer von seinem Vater die Favoriten abspeichern lassen. Und dann habe ich mich trotzdem gefragt, wie findet er die wieder? Ja, natürlich, von den Fabikons. Ich fand das ganz spannend. Das einfach zu beobachten, wie er das macht. Und klar, die Bildsprache spielt da eine wichtige Rolle. Was sieht man, was man nicht lesen kann? Oder nur schwer lesen kann?
Die andere Sache, die du erwähnt hast, die wollte ich noch mal vertiefen. Du meintest, es gibt eine Verordnung, eine Bundesverordnung, die jetzt Webseiten oder sogar informationstechnische Systeme, ich weiß nicht, Barrierefreiheit vorschreibt. Was ist das? Also die mit den 66...
Die TVs, die übersetzung, also die technischen Anforderungen sind die Übersetzung der WCAG 1. Diese WCAG 1 sind ja aus dem Jahr 1999 und die verpflichtet erst mal Bundesbehörden zur Barrierefreiheit in der IT. Also nicht nur Websites, sondern auch Anwendungen, CD-ROMs etc.
Von wem wurde das jetzt erlassen? Also von welchem Ministerium geht das eigentlich aus?
Was ist denn das?
Das ist seitdem ein paar Mal umsortiert worden. Also die Zuständigkeit ist im Augenblick beim BMAS, also Arbeit und Soziales.
Das ist natürlich beim BMGS.
Und BMI war auch noch mit dran beteiligt. Die Ausführende Behörde. Ausführende Behörde ist im Augenblick des Bundesverwaltungsamt, wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung habe in Köln. Aber die ist im Prinzip eigentlich mittlerweile Geschichte. Also wie Jan gesagt hat, die BITV 1.0, nenne ich sie jetzt mal, wie sie im Augenblick noch gilt. Die WCAG 1.0 aus dem Jahr 1999, darauf basiert sie, ist dann in Folge dessen ins Deutsch übersetzt worden, in eine Verordnung gegossen worden. Das W3C hat aber mittlerweile eine neue Version der WCAG rausgebracht, diese WCAG 2.0, WCAG 2.0.
Was versteht denn das WCAG?
Web Content Accessibility Guidelines, also die Zugänglichkeitsrichtlinien für Web-Inhalte, so ist die.
Das heißt aber, diese BITV, auch wenn sie jetzt von Informationstechnik redet, redet auch nur über Webseiten?
Im Prinzip schon. Im Verordnungstext redet sie über informationstechnische Systeme und CD-ROMs und ich weiß nicht alles, aber die 66 Kriterien, die zu erfüllen sind, sind nur auf Webseiten anwendbar. Also insofern, damit kann man jetzt nicht testen, ob ein Geldautomat zugänglich ist, weil ein Geldautomat eben anders funktioniert als eine Webseite. Deswegen, also sie gilt eigentlich, obwohl es in der Verordnung anders steht, ist sie nur auf Webseiten anwendbar.
Und die bezieht sich jetzt auch nur auf Bundesbehörden?
Nein, die Bundes-BETV bezieht sich auf, so heißt es im Juristen, träger öffentlicher Gewalt des Bundes. Das ist also alles, was Bundesrecht ausführt. Das sind natürlich die Bundesministerien, die obersten Bundesbehörden. Es sind aber dann auch irgendwelche Bundesanstaltführer, egal was, derer gibt es ja auch genug. Und es sind witzigerweise teilweise auch gesetzliche Krankenversicherungen.
Die mehr aus zwei Ländern?
Ja, also das sind so ein paar handwerkliche, naja, Klöpse, weiß ich nicht, ob das Absicht ist, aber ganz konkretes Beispiel, die AUK Rheinland fällt nicht unter die Bundes-BETV, weil wie der Name schon sagt, sie ist die AUK für das Rheinland. Aber eine kleine Betriebskrankenklasse von irgendeinem Metallverarbeitenden Betrieb im Dreiländereck Niedersachsen, Nordrhein-Westfalen, Nordhessen, die zufälligerweise Versicherte in allen drei Bundesländern hat, aber irgendwie nur 200 Mitglieder hat, die fällt unter die Bundesvorordnung. Aber die AUK Rheinland mit mehreren Millionen Versicherten eben nicht.
Aber abgesehen davon, es gibt ja auch Länderverordnungen, die mehr oder weniger parallel aufgebaut sind und die beziehen dann die Landesbehörden und die Landesämter, wie die auch alle heißen, Anstalten und teilweise auch Kommunen bis hin zu Gerichten, dass es vom Bundesland zu Bundesland ein bisschen unterschiedlich ist.
Bei uns in NRW ist sogar der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk mit drin. WDR steht explizit mit drin. Es gibt unterschiedliche Formen. Es gibt ein paar Länder, die haben sehr gute Landesbetv. Es gibt wie in NRW zum Beispiel eine ganz geschickte Landesbetv. Die haben sich ganz einfach gemacht und haben so einen Auto-Update damit eingebaut. Die haben einfach nur Fristen gesetzt. Dann reißt die Verordnung ab und sagt, alles weitere lesen Sie bitte in der Bundesbetv nach. Sobald die Bundesbetv sich aktualisiert, ist die Landesbetv quasi auto-aktualisiert.
Verstehe, die hatten einfach keine Lust, sich selber etwas einfallen zu lassen.
Nee, die hatten einfach ein eingebautes Update und sind damit immer auf dem neuesten technischen Stand.
Aber auch das machen nicht alle Länder.
Das machen leider auch nicht alle Länder. Manche haben eben sich so eine Betv-Leit verordnet. Auch mit ziemlich wischibaschi Texten, für wen das gilt und vor allen Dingen, für wen das alles nicht gilt und die Kriterien eingeschränkt. Also es ist ein relativer Wildwuchs. Es gibt aber jetzt im Bund demnächst wohl eine neue Betv 2.0. Die ist im Augenblick schon in der Pipeline, in der Mache. Sie ist nur noch nicht veröffentlicht, soll. Aber soweit ich das per Flurfunk gehört habe, in den nächsten Tagen oder Wochen zumindest den Behindertenverbänden vorgestellt werden.
Und die orientiert sich dann auch an dem neuen WCAG-Standard?
Die orientiert sich an dem WCAG-Standard, ja. Damit ist sie auf dem Stand von Ende 2008. Also wirklich up to date.
Gut, dann sollten wir vielleicht auch darauf eingehen. Wir sind jetzt sehr breit in dem Themenfeld unterwegs gewesen. Das finde ich auch gut. Schwerpunkt sollte ja auch ein bisschen die Webseiten konkret sein, weil das ist einfach nun mal das, wo die meisten Informationen heutzutage einfach landen. Das ist ja auch eure Spezialität. Jetzt hast du ja schon gesagt, Tomas, dass die WCAG letztlich auch so ein Spin-Off letzten Endes der Aktivitäten des Webstandards-Projektes gewesen ist, was nicht, habe ich dich falsch verstanden, dass das nicht auch Einfluss gehabt hat oder dass das Webstandards-Projekt Einfluss hat da drauf, ich fasse nicht.
Das ist sehr eng zusammenhängend.
Das ist so Arbeit.
Ja, gut, was auch immer da was beeinfluss haben mag. Tatsache ist, dass dieses Konsortium irgendwann unter dem Dach der W3C mal zusammengekommen ist und die ersten Standards eben 99 veröffentlicht hat. Und jetzt ist neun Jahre lang nicht viel passiert sozusagen. Und jetzt gibt es die neue Version. Die ist jetzt, was hast du gesagt, vor drei Wochen rausgekommen? Ende Dezember 2008 rausgekommen. Was umfasst denn jetzt diese WCAG? Ist das ein gutes Werk? Ist das irgendwie komplexer Paragrafenmüll, den keiner umsetzen kann? Oder ist das ein praktisches Handbuch, was man sich unbedingt mal durchlesen sollte? Wie muss man das nehmen?
Es ist eine ganz, ganz elegante Richtlinie geworden. Die Leute, die die entwickelt haben, die haben sich teilweise neun Jahre lang bis aufs Messer bekämpft. Aber sie haben sich immer alle wieder zusammengerauft, weil sie doch alle der Meinung waren, wir haben einen guten Zweck, für den wir da arbeiten. Wer engagiert sich da in diesen Konsorten? IBM hat da sehr viel Geld reingepumpt im Augenblick. Da sind große Softwarehersteller, Adobe, Microsoft und so weiter sind da mit drin. Da sind sämtliche Browserhersteller drin vertreten. Es sind einige Forschungsinstitutionen, oder sehr viele amerikanische Universitäten, aber auch Fraunhofer aus Deutschland hat da mitgearbeitet. Und die Behindertenverbände? Die sind natürlich auch immer wieder gehört worden, haben auch mitgearbeitet, Leute auch abgestellt. Auch die Deutschen? Nee, die gerade nicht. Also da kamen nicht so wirklich viele.
Sondern eher die amerikanischen Leute?
Nee, das ist weltweit alle außer Deutschland.
Hat das einen Grund?
Nein, das stimmt. Also das kann man so nicht sagen, dass sich niemand aus Deutschland engagiert hat.
Ihr hättet euch mehr wünschen können?
Wir hätten uns mehr gewünscht, das ganz sicher. Aber es ist, wie gesagt, es ist jetzt eine wirklich, wie ich finde, tolle Richtlinie daraus geworden, weil die sehr, sehr verständlich ist. Die hat eigentlich einen ganz simplen Aufbau. Es gibt nämlich eigentlich nur noch vier Prinzipien, die man sich merken sollte. Es gibt noch keine offizielle deutsche Übersetzung, also ich sage mal die englischen. Diese vier grundlegenden Prinzipien sind Perceivable, also wahrnehmbar, operable, also bedienbar, understandable, verständlich und robust, also technisch robust. Macht ein ziemlich doofes Akronym POR, P-U-U-R hört sich nach ARM, wie schrecklich. Also kein tolles Akronym, aber es ist eine ganz gute Eselsbrücke.
Also POR heißt ja eigentlich ein Gießen.
Ja, aber es klingt schon wie POR-Bunny.
Hätte man vielleicht die Reihenfolge erinnern sollen?
Nein, es gab, das darf man gar nicht.
Sagen, es gab mal noch eine 5. Das geht gar nicht. Naja, also mit der Schlagzeile, die Internet ist vor PORN, hätte man dann ja ganz gut werben können.
Aber das sind wirklich die grundlegenden Prinzipien, auf die man sich als Web-Entwickler, als Web-Designer einfach einlassen muss.
Die ersten drei verstehe ich, die vierte verstehe ich nicht. Also passivable, operable, understandable, das ist alles understandable. Aber was ist mit robust gemeint?
Das ist im Prinzip die Unterstützung der anderen W3C-Standards. Also schreib deinen HTML so, dass Browser da draußen vernünftigen Dokumentenbaum generieren können. Und zwar auch zukünftige Browser. Maximise compatibility with current and future user agent und dann including assistive technologies. Also baue Sachen ein, damit Benutzeragenten im weitesten Sinne jetzt und in Zukunft damit klarkommen.
Das ist dann technisch robust.
Dieser robuste Teil ist eigentlich nichts anderes als der Verweis auf die anderen Standards?
Nicht ganz, weil diese einzelnen Punkte, also das ist ganz interessant bei der WCAG2, die besteht aus einem normativen Teil, worüber wir gerade gesprochen haben. Also diese vier Prinzipien mit einzelnen Richtlinien. So ungefähr 20, ich habe sie nicht gezählt, aber so ungefähr. Und die verweisen wieder auf andere Dokumente. Und da steht alle Hand drin. Also das sind die eigentlichen Techniken, die man berücksichtigen kann. Es fängt bei HTML an und geht hin bis Area. Und da gibt es Beispiele. Also eine kurze Erläuterung mit einem kleinen Beispiel. Und weiterführende Links zu jedem dieser einzelnen Richtlinien. Und das ist natürlich etwas komplexer, weil für eine Richtlinie gibt es dann halt einzelne, also noch granularer aufgeschlüsselte Einzelkriterien, wie man mit Grafiken, Überschriften, was aus sich im Zusammenhang mit einer bestimmten Richtlinie umgehen soll. Und dann gibt es dann für jeden, für jedes dieser einzelnen Kriterien dann eben diese Beschreibungen mit Beispielen.
Und dann gibt es dann diese Techniken, die ich einsetzen kann, um den einen Punkt zu erfüllen. Also wir haben quasi an der Spitze die vier Prinzipien, dann haben wir so einen Mittelbau, das sind nur zwölf Punkte. Das ist dann der normative Teil der Richtlinie. Das ist wirklich dann der de facto Standard, den dann auch zum Beispiel ein Gesetzgeber nehmen könnte und daraus eben dann eine BTV 2.0 machen könnte. Wie diese Punkte dann zu erfüllen sind, das steht wieder Jan, er sagt dann eben in Techniken, die sind nicht normativ. Die sind einfach erklärende Texte dazu. Die sind allein schon deswegen nicht normativ, damit das W3C die schneller ändern kann. Wenn das irgendwas, ups. Wenn die auch normativ wäre, dann würden die in einem viel strikteren Prozess unterliegen, um wieder geändert werden zu können, wenn es technische Änderungen im Web gab und so weiter. Aber die sind der eigentliche Kern der Richtlinie für Web-Entwickler. Also wenn Web-Entwickler sich damit beschäftigen müssen, die sollten auf jeden Fall die vier Prinzipien mal gelesen haben, mal davon gehört haben, den ganzen Mittelbau vergessen. Der Mittelbau ist wirklich nur für Leute, die Verordnungen schreiben oder die Prüftools schreiben oder Testverfahren entwickeln und so weiter. Und die Techniken, die ganz hinten dran hängen, das ist der eigentlich interessante Teil dann wieder für Web-Entwickler. Und da gibt es vom W3C eine ganz wunderbare Checkliste, das werden wir auch noch den Link nachliefern, wo man sich das selber zusammenklicken kann. Also die haben quasi so die magische Technikenschrumpfungsliste erstellt, wo man sagen kann, also heute mache ich das nur CSS. Klickt alles weg, was irgendwie JavaScript und HTML ist und so weiter. Und dann sieht man, wie das Rollbalken kürzer wird und die Liste schrumpft.
Okay, von dem eigenen Arbeitsprofil, was man sozusagen hat, kann man sagen, bitte zeig mir nur das an, was mich betrifft.
Zeig mir nur CSS heute. Oder morgen mache ich JavaScript, dann mache ich alles andere auslassen und JavaScript an, dann kriege ich nur die Kriterien mit...
Verstehe.
Und morgen gibt es Untertitel. Das ist eine richtig tolle Sache. Wenn man diese ganzen Verordnungs- und Richtlinien wo es weglässt und sich wirklich als Web-Entwickler auf die Techniken konzentriert, da lernt man so dermaßen viel. Das sind wirklich mit Code-Listings und Design-Beispielen und so weiter wirklich toll. Die sind aber noch nicht komplett. Da darf man nicht erwarten, dass da jetzt wirklich alle Fälle, die im täglichen Agenturgeschäft auftreten, irgendwie erschlagen sind, sondern die sind noch in der Pipeline. Das war halt einfach das Ziel des W3C, jetzt erstmal die Guidelines aus der Tür rauszukriegen und dann mit den Techniken jetzt dann nachzuarbeiten.
Das heißt, da wird jetzt noch nachgeliefert?
Da wird noch nachgeliefert. Aber die ändern sich unter Umständen täglich. Da sind die also jetzt gerade ganz intensiv wieder dran, da noch Techniken zu liefern. Und, das ist das Schöne an dieser Konstruktion, in den WCAG 1.0, die regelt ja nur Standards oder Techniken, die das W3C selber auch ersondert. Also in dem Fall halt HTML, CSS und Ende-Erfahrenstange. Damals, 1999, gab es noch nicht viel mehr. Jetzt sind die Techniken, die ganze Konstruktion ist so, dass auch Hersteller von anderen Formaten, über die das W3C nicht die Kontrolle hat, also Beispiel Adobe Flash, PDF und ähnliches, auch Techniken veröffentlichen können, die sich eben auf bestimmte Checkpunkte in der WCAG beziehen. Aber eben Techniken dazu sind, wie mache ich Flash-Barrierefrei oder wie mache ich PDF-Barrierefrei. Oder bei JavaScript, was ja normativ ECMA-Script ist, kann man halt eben irgendwo hingehen und sagen, ich baue jetzt die Techniken, wie ich ECMA-Script barrierefrei umsetze. Und das wird eben jetzt dann alles nachgeliefert. Da sind auch teilweise eben dann einfach die Hersteller in der Pflicht.
Was ist das überhaupt für so ein Konvolut? Wie dick ist diese Spezifikation?
Mindestens 400, 500 Seiten.
Ja, aber ganz locker. Es gab mal einen Zwischenstand, der war ausgedruckt 200 Seiten. Da waren aber noch keine Techniken dabei. Und da war noch sehr viel Debugging-Code mit drin. Also so Editorial Notes, die noch irgendwo drin standen und so weiter. Also habe ich mir irgendwann mal den Spaß gemacht, die auszudrucken. Ich meine, es wären über 200 Seiten gewesen oder so. Aber jetzt im Augenblick... Weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht die Richtlinie. Die WCAG selber, ich drücke mal gerade hier auf Apfel P 32 Seiten. Und in sehr großer Schrift. Also wenn ich da die Schrift noch ein bisschen kleiner mache, dann sind so irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, 20. Also nichts, was man nicht lesen könnte.
Also ich finde das ein ziemlich bemerkenswertes Dokument. Ich habe hier gerade mal so einen Blick drauf geworfen. Also hier gibt es so Guidelines, was weiß ich, ich habe jetzt mal hier meine Reise rausgepickt. Da gibt es so eine Guideline, die sagt irgendwie, enough time. Lass den Benutzern genug Zeit, den Content zu lesen. Und dann gibt es daneben dann, also das erstmal erklärt, worum es irgendwie geht, so, dass man es irgendwie, das Timedimit irgendwie einstellen können soll und so weiter. Und dass es Warnungen gibt und Exceptions und tralala. Und dann gibt es dazu sogar nochmal eine Erklärung, wie man die jetzt erfüllt und dann auch nochmal, wie man das hier irgendwie alles versteht, wenn man es immer noch nicht verstanden hat. Also es sieht so aus, als ob die Guideline auch auf sich selbst angewendet wurde. Dass man die Möglichkeit hat, das zu verstehen.
Also es ist, da haben wir auch sehr viel, gerade in der letzten Phase nochmal sehr viel Energie reingesteckt. Das ist wirklich wesentlich verständlicher geworden als vorangegangene Entwürfe. Und eine ganz wichtige Sache, fast schon der wichtigste Unterschied zwischen der 1.0 und der 2.0 ist, es ist alles testbar. Die WCAG 1.0 hat sehr viele schöne Forderungen, wäre nett. Und wenn das Web wirklich so funktionieren würde, dann wäre es nur teilweise nicht umsetzbar, was da drin stand, oder technisch veraltet, oder es war so formuliert, dass man nicht überprüfen konnte, ob dieser Punkt jetzt tatsächlich erfüllt ist. Also wenn man da zwei Leute vorgesetzt hat, die ein Angebot getestet haben, um zu verifizieren, ist jetzt dieser Checkpoint erfüllt, dann kamen die bei sehr vielen nie zum gleichen Testergebnis. Bei der WCAG 2.0 ist es jetzt tatsächlich so, jeder einzelne Punkt, der da drin steht, ist auch wirklich entweder direkt maschinell oder auch so eine Mensch-Maschine-Kombination, also Software wird von Software beim Prüfen unterstützt oder jetzt gerade wenn so Verständlichkeit geht, da kann man kein Programm drauf lassen, von einem Menschen testbar und mehrere Tester müssen dann auch zu einem gemeinsamen Ergebnis kommen. Und was auch ganz wichtig ist, alles was da drin steht, ist auch implementierbar. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Schritt bei W3C-Standards. Seit einigen Jahren ist alles was normativ ist, da muss der Nachweis geführt worden sein, dass es implementierbar ist. Also das, was da drin steht, muss auch bewiesenermaßen schon mal im Netz genauso umgesetzt worden sein.
Das ist eine ganz neue Qualität bei W3C.
Ja, das ist eine ganz neue Qualität. Weil das ist, wenn ich mir so HTML4 angucke und gerade bei HTML4 im Bereich Formulare, was da teilweise ein Unsinn drin steht, und was die dafür aber alles vergessen haben, was es alles für Elemente nicht gibt, die wir aber ganz dringend bräuchten und die dann so sehr viel Wildwuchs geführt haben, diese Versäumnisse, ist das schon eine ganz neue Qualität in W3C-Standards. Ja, absolut.
Das erklärt vielleicht auch, warum es so lange gedauert hat, weil teilweise waren die Forderungen sehr, sehr hoch. Und dann hat man ja auch gesagt, wir brauchen Beispiele. Wir brauchen erstmal Beispiele. Und ja, da geht das Prozesse wieder von vorne los. Also ich kann mich erinnern, in 2005, bald ist es so weit, 2006, bald ist es so weit, bis Ende des Jahres, 2007 und so weiter, bis es endlich endlich ist.
Ja, die haben jedes Jahr, seit 1999, jedes Jahr gesagt, nächstes Jahr sind wir fertig. Aber jetzt sind sie fertig, es ist toll geworden.
Und jetzt müssen wir uns wirklich damit auseinandersetzen.
Jetzt ist es Sache des Bundes, natürlich erstmal da in der Bundesverordnung drauf zu machen. Und am besten natürlich im Interesse der Leute, die es umsetzen müssen, natürlich möglichst, sollte die zu 100 Prozent kompatibel sein. Und nicht von dem internationalen Standard abweichen, weil es natürlich für einen IT-Dienstleister irgendwie in seinen Projektteams auch schwer zu vermitteln. Heute arbeiten wir für einen privatwirtschaftlich organisierten Kunden, da musst du die Richtlinie anwenden und morgen arbeitest du aber für Bundesbehörde XY. Dann machst du bitte was ganz anderes. Also insofern wäre es schon ganz sinnvoll, wenn die Bundesverordnung wirklich zu 100 Prozent kompatibel zu den internationalen Standards wäre.
Jetzt natürlich so, dass eine Firma, wenn sie irgendwie die Möglichkeit hat, jetzt ein neues Produkt zu entwickeln, natürlich nicht unbedingt jetzt als erstes 500-Seiten-Dokumente aus dem Standardregal rauszieht und sagt, ach komm, jetzt haben wir gerade zu viel Zeit, jetzt implementieren wir das einfach mal, weil wir eh nichts Besseres zu tun haben. Ihr werdet da ja sicherlich auch einige Erfahrungen mit gesammelt haben. Was ist denn die Motivation, die eine Firma eigentlich, ja, also wie soll eine Firma eine Motivation entwickeln? Was hat sie davon sozusagen, sich diesen Standard anzuschauen? Also ich meine, ich kann das ja auch alles ignorieren irgendwie. Ich bau hier meinen Start-up, ich hab da irgendwie meine Zielgruppe, die sind alle ganz jung, haben alle ganz viel Geld, sind alle ganz begeisterungsfähig und so weiter und dann kommen die alle und dann ist alles prima. So, bei einer Behörde ist klar, das ist eine andere Geschichte. Die sind jetzt auch gesetzlich dazu verpflichtet, das zu machen. Aber auch wer verpflichtet wird, quält sich ja eher, als dass er da Begeisterung hat. Also was hat man davon, wenn man sowas wie die WCAG in seine Webseite mit einbaut oder die Guidelines, die Richtlinien, die da drin sind, berücksichtigt?
Ja, man kann das ja verschiedenlich sehen. Also ich kann vielleicht mit einer kleinen Geschichte einfach beginnen. Mein Vater ist normal gesund, sage ich mal, etwas älter, aber über 70. Und wenn er jetzt irgendwo fliegen möchte, in Urlaub, der fährt als Rentner vielleicht zwei-, dreimal im Jahr irgendwo hin, entscheidet er, seine Entscheidung beruht einzig allein darauf, wie chaotisch die Webseite ist. Also wenn eine Seite chaotisch ist, er nicht damit klarkommt, und sagt, nee, da kauf er nicht. Also ganz klar, dann geht er dann halt eben zur Konkurrenz. Und Barrierefreiheit hat natürlich ein bisschen was mit Aufgeräumtheit zu tun, ganz klar. Wenn etwas übersichtlich ist, haben sich die Leute oft halt vor lange Gedanken gemacht. Dann sind meistens auch Strukturen berücksichtigt worden. Man spricht eben größere Zielgruppen an, zum Beispiel eben die Senioren. Und nicht nur die 20- bis 30-Jährigen, die irgendwas Aktuelles nachgehen.
Ich habe im Englischen einen schönen Satz gehört, der das wirklich so prägnant auf den Punkt bringt. Designing for our future selves. Wie möchtest du, dass das web ist, wenn du später mal eine Behinderung entwickelt hast? Wir haben als Menschen einfach eine ganz große Chance. Es gibt da von der WHO irgendwelche Zahlen, dass man mit 60 eine 25 und mit 70 schon eine 50-prozentige Chance drauf hat, die eine oder andere Form der motorischen, sensorischen, was auch immer, Behinderungen zu entwickeln. Also ich gestalte das Web jetzt so, wie ich möchte, dass es dann später mal ist, wenn ich darauf angewiesen bin, dass es so ist, wie es ist.
Ja, aber diese Sicht hat man ja einfach nicht. Das ist sehr schön altruistisch und klar. Das beinschätzt man erst, wenn es wehtut.
Nein, es gibt natürlich auch immer wieder die Frage, aber was bringt mir das betriebswirtschaftlich? Also eine ganz klare Antwort auf die Frage, was bringt mir solche Standards? Wenn ich meine Entwickler dazu zwinge, standardkonformen Code zu schreiben, dann kann ich im Prinzip jedem Entwickler, der in der Lage ist, sauberen Code zu lesen, auch davor sitzen und er wird 0 Sekunden Einarbeitungszeit benötigen, um sich in den Code einzuarbeiten, weil das einfach Code ist, der eben nachbestimmt wenig. Klar, aber wenn ich so an früher zurückdenke, irgendwie mit dreifach verschachtelten Layout-Tabellen und jeder war noch ein Spacer-Gift drin, um einen Browser irgendwo zu einer Darstellung zu bringen, woran ich mich nie mehr erinnere, warum ich das so eingebaut habe, das ist schon was anderes als sauberen Code nach den Standards irgendwo hinzuschreiben und nach fünf Jahren weiß ich noch, was ich damit gemeint habe.
Und der saubere Code ist auch in gewisser Weise gerät unabhängig, also jetzt nicht nur die Screenreader, sondern man kommt auch mit dem Handy ganz gut dran an dieser Information. Das ist zwar meistens suboptimal, aber es ist zumindest besser als eine Tabelle. Und ich weiß noch, als der Landtag NRW 2005 an eine Biene gewonnen hat, der zuständige Mitarbeiter war nachher mit seinem PDA durch die Gegend gelaufen und sagte, es ist so toll, weil er das alles mit seinem PDA lesen konnte. Aber gut, okay, das sind halt so die Nebeneffekte von der Standard-Konformität. Entschuldigung, ich hab dich.
Aber das ist ein sehr valider Punkt, ich meine, in zunehmendem Maße. Also es gibt ja nicht nur jetzt die Handys oder die PDAs und die Computer. Und ich denke, wir nehmen jetzt auch gerade so mit dem Aufkommen von Netbooks und so weiter. Es wird einfach immer mehr spezialisierte Geräte geben, die nicht unbedingt jetzt die höchsten Prozessor- oder Betriebssystem- Anforderungen erfüllen können. Die aber auch in irgendeiner Form am Internet teilnehmen und die natürlich auch alles irgendwie lesen wollen.
Gut, das darf man natürlich auch nicht zu weit spinnen, so Dinge wie eine Verschlankung. Würde dann ja heißen, dass man noch ein paar Bites einspart, wenn man den Blinden die Alternativtexte zu Bildern wegnimmt und so weiter. Dann wären sie halt natürlich schon Performanter für die Sehenden. Aber das ist dann auch nicht unbedingt im Sinne des Erfinders. Schwierig, so in die Richtung zu argumentieren.
Also ich habe so den Eindruck, eigentlich auch aus meiner Erfahrung heraus, dass man in dem Moment, wo man... Also wenn ich mir diese Guidelines so anschaue, ich blätter so ein bisschen dieses Ding, erzeugt den Inhalt, dass er irgendwie so und so dargestellt werden kann, versuche irgendwie alternative Beschreibungen ran zu machen, das ist ja eigentlich so ein bisschen der Klassiker, aber eben auch so wie die Sache mit der Zeit, die ich schon erwähnt habe, oder eben auch diese, kannst du mit der Tastatur benutzen oder sollte mit der Tastatur benutzbar sein. Es sind ja eigentlich klare Vorschriften, die einem immer wieder Anlass geben, darüber nachzudenken, was man da eigentlich tut. Und in dem Moment, wo es auch testbar ist, schafft man ja auch, du hast es schon gesagt, so Einarbeitungszeiten oder Mitarbeiter, das ist auf jeden Fall auch so ein Aspekt, aber ich habe immer festgestellt, wenn ich solche Methodiken auf mein Werk anwende, dann frage ich mich einfach auch immer selber, was mache ich da eigentlich und vermeide eigentlich auch bestimmte Fehler, weil man einfach ein Framework sozusagen hat zur Überprüfung der eigenen Struktur. Könnt ihr das so bestätigen? Wie sind denn eure Erfahrungen? Ein Teil eurer Arbeit wird ja sicherlich auch, du hast gesagt, ihr macht ja beide Beratungen. Ihr habt ja dann sozusagen auch mit Firmen zu tun. Was ist denn so deren Interesse? Fühlen die sich jetzt eher von den Gesetzen getrieben oder gibt es da auch jetzt schon so eine Mehrheit oder zumindest einige, die jetzt sagen, ah nee, das tun wir, weil sie gute Menschen sind oder weil wir da jetzt auch wirklich eine Zielgruppe sehen?
Das ist sehr unterschiedlich. Also es gibt Leute, die tatsächlich sich vom Gesetz getrieben fühlen. Aber diese Projekte, die kommen meistens nicht zum gewünschten Ergebnis. Also so ein paar Minimalanforderungen werden zwar erfüllt, aber die Nutze haben die dann nicht im Blick. Und es gibt Leute, die ich sage mal ein bisschen sozialer ausgerichtet sind, die sehr motiviert sind, die auch engagiert sind. Und diese befassen sich erstmal mit dem Thema. Und natürlich im ersten Wurf, da schafft man nicht die Barrierefreiheit. Da schafft man vielleicht 20, 30, vielleicht auch 50 Prozent, je nachdem. Die interessieren sich dafür, die interessieren sich vor allem für die Nutzer. Und möchten eben, dass nicht nur die Behinderten, auch die Senioren, auch alle möglichen anderen Leute mit ihrem Angebot auch zufrieden sind. Und das ist für mich eigentlich eine selbstverständliche Haltung. Ich meine, wenn ich als Berater irgendwo bin, dann möchte ich ja auch, dass meine Kunden zufrieden sind. Also ich muss denen gute Informationen geben, richtige Informationen. Und genauso muss ein Web-Anbieter auch handeln.
Ja, ich habe auch sehr viele Kunden im öffentlichen Bereich, die einfach verpflichtet sind. Da muss ich mit dem Kunden gar nicht lange diskutieren, sondern der kommt oftmals auch gerade deswegen auf mich zu, weil er verpflichtet ist und da Hilfe braucht. Aber natürlich auch einige Kunden, die privatschwirtschaftlich organisiert sind. Und da ist es oft so, dass ich das Thema so ein bisschen unterm Radar halte. Also natürlich kriegen die auch die Zusage, dass das, was ich für sie produziere, geeignet ist, um hinterher zu sagen, wir haben alles mögliche unternommen, was im Rahmen des Budgets möglich war, um hinterher sagen zu können, das ist barrierefrei. Aber das sind sehr viele Sachen, die ich einfach so mache. Also ich mache seit Jahren keine Seiten mehr mit Lehrautabellen. Also ich wüsste auch gar nicht mehr, wie ich das jetzt... Also wenn ich jetzt eine Seite mit lernende, wie es geht, wüsste ich jetzt gar nicht mehr. Das sind einfach so Sachen, wo ich gar nicht mehr lange darüber rede. Die stehen zwar auch so in den Richtlinien drin, dass man das alles nicht macht und böse ist. Und ich versuche immer, möglichst Bilder, die Inhalte transportieren, mit sinnvollen Alternativtexten zu hinterlegen und so weiter. Einfach weil ich es... Ich mache es so. Das ist aber auch nichts, was dann irgendwie als extra Posten auf der Rechnung landet, sondern das ist einfach best practice heutzutage im Jahr 2009, das einfach sauberen Code abzuliefern. Und da geht auch nichts aus der Tür raus, was nicht irgendwie wenigstens ansatzweise validiert.
Ja gut, ich meine, das ist das, was du sozusagen als Leistung machst.
Gutes Handwerk eigentlich.
Das ist klar, das ist klar. Aber ich meine, wie kriegt man dieses Handwerk den Firmen vermittelt? Das ist jetzt eigentlich das, was mich sehr viel mehr interessiert. Also meine, gut, es gibt das Beispiel mit deinem Vater, Jan, das fand ich ja insofern ganz gut, weil ich meine, wenn man sich die Alterspyramide anschaut, also es ist in Deutschland ist es so, ja, es werden immer mehr Leute älter, also der Großteil der Zielgruppe, welche immer sie es auch ist, wird immer älter. Und klar, wenn man älter wird, dann sind Sehschwächen so ein Thema Verständnisschwächen, sage ich mal, ja, also wie hast du es für einen Schluss gesagt, chaotische Webseite, ja. Und das spricht ja eigentlich auch so für dieses, chaotisch ist es ja dann, wenn es keine Struktur hat. Genau, genau das meine ich. Und sprich, mehr Struktur kann einfach nur helfen, vielleicht sogar um das eigene Produkt besser zu verstehen, kann einem so dem einen oder anderen Projektleiter auch nicht schaden, aber eben letzten Endes, um auch vom Kunden wahrgenommen zu werden.
Also ich denke, ein Aspekt, was ich auf vielen Seiten vorfinde, ist mein persönlicher Eindruck, dass die Web-Anbieter diese Websites so nutzen, wie man so ein Blatt Papier benutzt. Also es wird so konzipiert, wie eine Werbe-Broschürde. Das wird ausgeteilt und so sieht es dann auch aus. Aber ich finde, das Web ist ein ganz anderes Medium. Und wenn ich einen Werbeprospekt bei mir im Postfach finde, ich kann es lesen, wenn ich mich dafür interessiere, dann kann ich da irgendwo anrufen oder was weiß ich. Aber im Web, wenn ich irgendwas nicht mag, weil es einfach schlecht aufbereitet ist, weil ich damit nicht klarkomme, weil es chaotisch ist oder sowas, dann werde ich selbstverständlich zur Konkurrenz gehen. Also es gibt viele Möglichkeiten, ich sag mal, in den Urlaub zu fliegen.
Mir geht es auch mit Werbebroschüren so.
Manchmal steht da gerade die Couch, die man gesucht hat. Also das passiert schon mal und das meiste landet natürlich im Altpapier. Ist klar, aber man guckt schon drauf. Also ich jetzt nicht, aber andere.
Die Frage war ja auch, wie kriegt man das in Unternehmen verkauft oder wie argumentiert man das? Das ist natürlich klar, was ich eben sagte, dass wir alle eine ganz gute Chance haben, wieder mal eine Behinderung zu entwickeln. Aber es ist letztendlich auch so, dass Menschen mit Behinderungen ja mitten unter uns sind und letztendlich genauso Mitbürger sind, die Angebote nutzen und informiert werden wollen und auch genauso jeden Tag was zu essen auf dem Tisch brauchen, wie wir alle auch. Und das ist nicht so, als wäre das jetzt unbedingt ein Thema für die Schmuddelecke. Wenn man mal genau nachguckt, glaubt man gar nicht, wie viele Menschen mit Behinderungen wirklich so in der Gesellschaft integriert sind, ohne dass es jetzt großartig auffällt, wenn die Gesellschaft bestimmte Voraussetzungen erfüllt. Dass die Gesellschaft eben den Menschen ermöglicht, auch mitzumachen. Und es ist eben nicht nur ein Randgruppenthema. Also ein bestes Beispiel, wenn mir dann irgendwer sagt, wir bei unseren Kunden sind nicht blind oder kognitiv behindert oder so was. Bestes Gegenbeispiel, mit einer Leserechtschreibschwäche kann man in England Premierminister werden. Tony Blair war Premierminister, ist aber nach wie vor Legastheniker. Mit Legasthenik kann man in Schweden König werden. Also der einzige Nicht-Legastheniker im schwedischen Könighaushaus ist die angeheiratete Königin. Und ansonsten haben wir uns als Komplett die gesamte Familie Leserechtschreibschwäche. Also das hindert die auch nicht daran, irgendwie König von Schweden zu werden.
Verstehe.
Und es gibt einige wenige Berühmtheiten, die auch so eine ganz starke Behinderung haben. Also zum Beispiel Herr Schäuble, den wir sicherlich alle sehen.
Der hat eine Notgesetz-Verständnisschwäche.
Verständnisschwäche?
Ich glaube, die haben gerade eine andere Behinderung.
Es gab einen Blindenminister in England auch. Und also auch ein Präsident der USA, einer der Roosevelt, saß auch schon mal in der Rollstuhl. Aber es bleibt nach wie vor die Ausnahme, dass Leute so prominent jeden Tag im Fernsehen zu sehen sind. Aber trotzdem, also ich meine, eine Behinderung sollte eigentlich jemanden nicht hindern, bestimmte Sachen zu machen. Zumindest bei bestimmten Behinderungen. Es gibt Behinderungsarten, die sehr stark einschränkend sind, ist ganz klar. Aber viele sind nur teilweise eingeschränkt und können also sind leistungsfähig, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, wer weiß schon, mit wieviel blinden er es zu tun hatte, als er bei seiner Hotline für was weiß ich angerufen hat.
Ja, sicher. Es gibt ganz klare Grenzen. Also es gibt sicher Behinderungsformen, die den Nutzer tatsächlich effektiver von abhaltendes Internet produktiv zu nutzen. Also wenn jemand wirklich von Geburt an taubblind ist, der hat in der Regel ganz andere Probleme als Probleme bei der Computernutzung. Sondern es sind viel grundlegendere Schwierigkeiten. Also da gibt es schon deutliche Grenzen. Oder auch gerade im Bereich kognitive Behinderungen ist es natürlich schon schwieriger, weil da haben wir so einen fließen Übergang. Weil es gibt keine Grenze zwischen verstehen und nicht verstehen. Zwischen hört nichts und sieht nichts.
Hängt bei jedem woanders an.
Das ist klar. Aber der Übergang zwischen verstehen und nicht verstehen ist ja auch eher ein fließender und kann unter Umständen dann doch noch erlernt werden mit einem gewissen Training und so weiter. Aber da reden wir natürlich dann schon über, im Gegensatz zu taubblinden Menschen, über wirkliche Zahlen. Also von bis zu, wenn man mal so eine Intelligenzkurve aufzeichnet und dann mal guckt, ab wo ist eine Lernbehinderung. Ja, Lernbehinderung gibt es im ganzen Intelligenzspektrum. Eine wirkliche kognitive Behinderung, was als Grenze angenommen wird, ist so ein IQ von 70 und drunter. Das sind trotzdem immer noch 12 bis 15 Prozent der Bevölkerung. Und das sind natürlich dann schon teilweise, da kommen echte Zahlen zustande. Das ist teilweise für Web-Anbieter irrelevant. Also ganz doofes Beispiel, jemand mit einer schweren kognitiven Behinderung, den muss ich als E-Commerce-Anbieter nicht unbedingt berücksichtigen, weil ich unter Umständen Schwierigkeiten haben werde, den Nachweis zu führen, dass der Nutzer die AGBs zur Kenntnis genommen und verstanden hat. Und damit ist kein Kauf zustande gekommen, wenn ich das nicht nachweisen kann. Also auch da gibt es ganz deutliche Grenzen, wo du sagen kannst, sorry, da können wir jetzt als Anbieter von Webseiten nichts mehr machen. Da sitzt so ein großes Problem vor dem Computer, dass wir das nicht abfangen können. Aber wie gesagt, es ist ein fließender Übergang und letztendlich ist es die Aufgabe der Richtlinien, die Grenze dieses Übergangs immer noch ein bisschen weiter zu verschieben. Also jedes Jahr können wir noch ein bisschen mehr machen und noch ein bisschen mehr machen.
Was sind denn so eure, wenn wir jetzt vielleicht mal von den großen Organisationen und den Firmen mit unbegrenzten Budgets mal weggehen und vielleicht auch mal so den kleinen Webdesigner ansprechen. Ich meine, war noch immer ich eine neue Webseite mal aufsetze, denke ich mir halt auch immer wieder so, was könnte ich denn jetzt mal so alles berücksichtigen. Gerade wenn das so ein Freizeitprojekt ist, dann hat man natürlich jetzt was besseres zu tun als vielleicht die komplette WCAG durchzuarbeiten. Aber vielleicht habt ihr ja mal so ein paar Tipps oder vielleicht, ich würde gerne mal so was hören, was ist denn so das Wichtigste? Also was sollte man denn auf jeden Fall machen? Was sind vielleicht so ein paar Sachen, die auch ansonsten ganz praktisch sind, deshalb wenn man die macht, wo man auch noch andere Vorteile hat? Also was ist so die Best-of? Und an dich natürlich Jan auch so die Frage, was hilft dir sozusagen jetzt als, also was hilft Sehbehinderten am meisten? Also welche blöden Fehler kann man da von vornherein vermeiden, um es nicht sinnlos inkompatibel zu gestalten?
Ich glaube, um es vorwegzunehmen, eine Checkliste oder sowas wirst du nicht bekommen, weil es sehr stark davon abhängt, wen du jetzt genau vor dir hast. Also ich jetzt als Screenreader-Nutzer mag natürlich gerne, wenn eine Seite gut strukturiert ist, durchdacht. Also für mich leicht lernbar. Jede Seite ist auch ein bisschen anders. Da gibt es auch nicht die goldenen Regeln. Also zum Beispiel, dass eine Überschrift Ebene 1 den Inhalt einleitet. Das mag ich persönlich sehr gerne. Wenn du auf einfach für alle gehst, ich weiß gar nicht, wie der aktuelle Stand ist, aber früher gab es 3 H1. Zwei waren vor dem Inhalt. Gut, dann muss ich dreimal auf die 1 drücken. Auch kein Problem. Ich komme damit klar. Aber generell, also auch Tabellenlisten, also Datentabellendisten und alles andere, was strukturiert werden kann, sollte aus meiner Sicht strukturiert werden. Aber schwierig wird es schon, wenn du jetzt verschiedene Sehbehinderte fragst. Die einen werden sagen, große Schrift, die anderen werden sagen, gute Kontraste. Ein Farblinder könnte sagen, bitte kein Rot. Warum auch immer. Also es gibt so viele unterschiedliche Gründe, warum jemand sich eingeschränkt fühlt.
Das ist klar. Ich meine, vielleicht gibt es ja einfach so ein paar Sachen, mit denen man jetzt den meisten nicht unbedingt ein Problem schafft, oder den auf jeden Fall immer hilft.
Für den Einstieg würde ich sagen, ein standardkonformer Seitenaufbau mit HTML und CSS ist schon mal nicht schlecht.
In welchem Standard sollte man da folgen?
Keine Layout-Tabellen. Layout-Tabellen sind bäh bäh.
Also alles, was mit Layout und Formatierung zu tun hat, bitte in die CSS. Die Seite sollte, also in diesem Anfangsstadium natürlich, möglichst auch ohne JavaScript funktionieren. Also der ganze Informationsaufbau dieser Seite sollte erst mal mit HTML realisiert worden sein, schön strukturiert und mit dem CSS dann eben so gestaltet, wie man es eigentlich haben möchte oder ungefähr haben möchte. Dann muss man...
Ist dieser neue Trend hin zu AJAX und so interaktiven Webseiten, wo dann auch viel im Client ausgeführt wird, ist das ein Problem?
Kein grundsätzliches Problem. Es ist im Detail manchmal schon ein Problem. Also es gibt da so leichte Inkompatibilitäten manchmal. Also Latency Issue ist ein solches Thema, wo, also wenn dynamisch was geändert wurde auf der Seite ohne das Zutun des Nutzers, da kriegt der Screenreader das gar nicht mit. Also aber wenn der Screenreader Nutzer ein Formular irgendwie angecheckt, also ein Checkbox angecheckt hat oder sowas, dann kriegt er die Veränderung schon mit. Das Problem hier ist eigentlich eine ganz andere. Der Screenreader Nutzer muss wissen, wo auf der Seite sich was geändert hat. Also wir bewegen uns hier schon im Bereich Usability für Screenreader. Und eine pauschale Lösung ist da eigentlich gar nicht gegeben.
Da gibt es zwar die wunderbare magische Spray-On-Instant-Accessibility-Lösung. Aha, bin ich gespannt. Das könnte wirklich eine Wunderwaffe werden. Es ist in der Tat ein Problem, was der Jan sagt. Das hängt ein bisschen wieder mit der Art und Weise zusammen, wie manche Hilfsmittel funktionieren. Also ganz grob vereinfacht gesagt, so ein Screenreader baut sich ein Modell der Seite on load, sobald die Seite geladen ist, und schreibt die in so einen virtuellen Puffer rein, und aus dem bedient er sich. Und da bedient er sich so lange, bis irgendwie die Seite neu geladen wird. Wenn die aber nicht klassisch neu lädt, sondern eben nur per Ajax irgendwie der aktuelle Börsencoaster reingeschoben wird oder irgendwas anderes passiert, dann kann und wird es passieren, dass manche Screenreader es unter Umständen nicht mitkriegen, wenn man sie nicht explizit darauf hinweist. Und das ist der wichtige Punkt. Es gibt einen Standard, der ist zwar noch in der Entwicklung beim W3C. Nennt sich WAI-Area, also W-A-I unter dem Bindestrich ARIA steht für Accessible Rich Internet Applications und das ist im Prinzip der fehlende Puzzlestein, der damals bei der Spezifikation von HTML4 vergessen wurde. Da sind sehr viele Sachen drin, für die es zum Beispiel in HTML4 keine Entsprechung gibt, aber die in sehr vielen Widgets gebraucht werden. Ganz plattes Beispiel, warum gibt es in HTML4 keinen Schieberegler? Brauche ich aber in sehr vielen Widgets. Oder warum gibt es keine Combo Box, also irgendwas, wo ich gleichzeitig eintippen und trotzdem was auswählen kann aus dem Dropdown und solche Geschichten. Die fehlen einfach. ARIA definiert einen ganzen Satz an Attributen und zugehörigen Werten, mit denen ich eben beliebigen Elementen eine Rolle mitgeben kann. Also du, Diff, hast die Rolle eines Sliders. Also du bist zwar ein Diff und damit erstmal inhaltsleer, semantisch wertbefreit quasi.
Aber was da drin ist, soll ein Slider sein.
Aber was da drin ist, hat die Rolle eines Sliders. Und das wird dann vom Browser und der Accessibility API auf die Controls, die so ein Betriebssystem nativ zur Verfügung stellt, gemapped. Das ist der eigentliche Trick-By-Way-Area. Dass dann darüber quasi die Hilfsmittel, die an der Schnittstelle dranhängen, in die Lage versetzt werden, da wirklich ein Schieberegler und dessen Wert links ist der und der aktuelle Wert ist der. Und dann schiebt der Benutzer rüber und dann kriegt er angesagt, wie die aktuellen Werte sind und der maximale Wert ist das. Also wirklich so ein natives Widget, wie man das aus dem Betriebssystem kennt und wie das Betriebssystem das auch zur Verfügung stellt, was aber, wie gesagt, dem HTML4 fehlt, kann man mit diesem Way-Area nachbilden. Anderes Beispiel für den Standard ist, und das ist ganz wichtig zu sagen, das funktioniert tatsächlich auch schon in aktuellen Screenreadern. Das funktioniert zum Beispiel in Jaws, was Marktführer ist in der aktuellen Version schon ganz wunderbar mit Browsern ab Firefox 1.5, der nun auch schon ein bisschen älter ist.
Wobei, ich meine, ich benutze noch Jaws 8, ich müsste noch eine Lizenz für Jaws 9 kaufen und ab Jaws 10 ist eine gute Unterstützung zu erwarten.
Das ist richtig. Das ist letztendlich das Problem bei Innovationen führen immer zu Brüchen. Das ist einfach so. Das ist aber nicht nur auf Screenreader beschränkt. Das ist so im richtigen Leben auch so.
Ich muss sagen, ich zucke ja ein bisschen zusammen, wenn ich den Begriff Screenreader höre. Das ist ja einfach dieses Konzept, dass erstmal ein Programm mühsam das HTML, wenn ich jetzt mal nur auf diesen Problembereich Web schaue, da habe ich jetzt so ein Programm, was sich irre bemüht, aus diesem HTML eine Seite zusammenzubauen, um sie mir dann anzuzeigen. Aber ich, der sich dann vielleicht gar nicht lesen kann, benutze dann wiederum einen Screenreader, der wiederum extrem bemüht ist, das, was irgendein Programm anzeigt, wieder zurückzubringen, obwohl ja eigentlich die Ursprungsstruktur, also sagen wir mal jetzt ein semantisch ausgeprägtes, wie du es eben auch gesagt hast, XML, eine viel, viel, viel bessere Basis gewesen wäre, um mir zu sagen, was eigentlich da drin ist. Also ist es nicht Zeit, dass man diese Screenreader-Funktionalität einfach in den Web-Browser selbst macht oder dass man einfach einen Web-Browser baut, der speziell für, weiß, weiß ich, bestimmte Behinderungen eben gemacht ist?
Um diesen Browser überhaupt starten zu können, braucht der Benutzer schon einen Screenreader.
Es ist ja nicht nur der Browser.
Nö, das kann ja auch so eine Box sein, die wirklich nichts anderes macht, als das Web zu lesen. So, da habe ich so ein Gerät, verstehst du, wie so ein kleiner iPod, der einfach nichts anderes tut, als Webseiten zu lesen und der, keine Ahnung, wo ich vielleicht noch die URL per Sprache eingeben kann, wie auch immer. Und ja, sie mir dann einfach immer so darstellt, weil ich meine, das war jetzt, du wirst dich ja gut dran erinnern, mit dem Webstandards-Projekt. Damals war das ja eine katastrophale Zeit. Da gab es irgendwie zwei Engines, die die Welt beherrschten und beide tauchten einfach gar nichts. Und das stelle ich jetzt mal so, das war auch meine Wahrnehmung. Es war einfach so. Heute gibt es mit so Entwicklungen wie WebKit, was ja derzeit drauf und dran ist, den Browser-Markt eigentlich zu übernehmen. Also Internet Explorer 2 ist rein zahlenmäßig immer noch eine große Verbreitung, bloß alle anderen Hersteller haben sich ja fast schon darauf geeinigt, diese Maschine als Basis zu nehmen. Wäre ja jetzt kein großer Schritt, da sozusagen direkt da anzusetzen, wo die Daten herkommen. Bis hin zu speziellen Seiten für Blinde, oder?
Also was träume ich jetzt? Es ist mehr als nur der Inhalt. Also der Screenreader muss jetzt vom Browser aus gesehen also den Inhalt lesen können. Und dafür gibt es ja das HTML bzw. andere Strukturelemente. Es gibt noch das Menü. Man will vielleicht auch trotzdem mal drucken oder Datei senden im Internet Explorer. Dann gibt es noch die Symbolleisten, irgendwelche Plugins und so weiter und so fort. Und so eine Software müsste sowas auch alles abfangen können. Also das ist mit einem Screenreader meistens möglich, weil er in diese verschiedenen Bereiche hineinspringen kann und diese auch nochmal strukturiert.
Das meine ich ja, wenn man Screenreader und Webbrowser einfach so miteinander verheiratet, dass es sich eigentlich um ein Programm handelt, weil dann muss er gar keine Tricks anwenden, um an irgendwas ranzukommen, er ist einfach schon da.
Es gibt Firefox-Erweiterungen, die sowas eigentlich schon machen.
Als Plugin.
IBM hat das auch mit dem IBM-Homepage wieder versucht. Die haben es aber eingestellt. Da gibt es nicht mehr.
Es gab es schon mal so einen sprechenden Sprachbrowser im Prinzip. Da sind sie aber daran gescheitert. Da hat sich der Markt nicht durchgesetzt. Letztendlich widerspricht er auf etwas, du gerade sagst mit Sonderseiten für Blinde usw. widerspricht es ja auch so ein bisschen dem Grundgedanken der Barrierefreiheit, dass eben letztendlich alle Menschen das gleiche Angebot nutzen, gleichberechtigt nutzen können und eben nicht auf Sonderwege verwiesen werden. Also ein ganz schönes Beispiel, wir haben es letzte Woche noch eingebaut, weil Jan das eben sagte, weil es immer ein Problem ist, wir haben einfach für alle die so ein Live-Search-Widget eingebaut, wo man um die Grenze ist los und tippt nach, schickt nach zwei Buchstaben mittlerweile, nach zwei, hatten das mal ein bisschen getestet, ob das von der Performance her, aber ist ganz gut, also da schickt die Eingaben los, kriegt eine Vorschlagsliste zurück, was da zu dem eingegebenen Wortfetzen dann an Treffern gefunden wurde und so weiter. Und die Liste kann man dann, die klappt dann aus, so quasi so eine nachgebaute Combo-Box, die kann man mit den Pfeiltasten durchgehen. Alles, was gerade fokussiert ist, wird hoch in die Textbox geschrieben. Und da sind jetzt eben so ein paar Sachen drin aus dem kommenden Bay Area-Standard. Der sagt nämlich, und das löst dieses Problem, was Jan eben meinte, das Screenreader das nicht immer mitkriegen, wenn es Änderungen gab. Man kann eben über dieses Area, über bestimmte Attribute, dem Screenreader sagen, Achtung, hier gibt es eine Änderung. Und dann gibt es eben zu diesem Attribut verschiedene Werte von sag dem Nutzer irgendwann mal Zeit, wenn er gerade mal irgendwie eine Pause gemacht hat, bis hin zu assertive oder rude zum Beispiel. Also wirklich unverschämt. Also unterbrech den Nutzer an der Arbeit. Ja, ja, der Wert ist rude. Also wirklich frech. Also unterbrech den Nutzer sofort bei der Arbeit, da ist jetzt gerade was ganz Schlimmes passiert. Und darüber kann man eben dann auch dem Screenreader mitteilen, da hat sich was geändert und aktualisiert diesen virtuellen Buffer automatisch, den der Screenreader ansonsten bis zum St. Nimmerleins-Tachen ohne Reload nicht aktualisiert hätte und so weiter. Also auch das Problem kriegt man damit gelöst. Ja, also wenn sich jemand mal für ein Beispiel von, wie man dieses Way Area in der Praxis umsetzt, einfach mal dabei einfach für alle in den Quelltext gucken, in der linken Spalte dieses Such-Widget oder so ist damit eben aufgebaut.
Also der Webseite kann man auf jeden Fall schon mal ansehen, dass Accessibility zu berücksichtigen nicht unbedingt bedeutet, dass man irgendwie eine schlecht funktionierende Webseite machen muss, sondern ganz im Gegenteil, eigentlich da auch alle Optionen offensteht. Ich würde jetzt so zum Abschluss, und ich denke, wir haben jetzt hier unsere Themen, Ziele schon so weitgehend erreicht. Ihr hattet ja auch einen Podcast, der gerade nicht läuft, hast du ja schon gesagt. Was mich mal interessieren würde, ist, wie jetzt, wir sind ja hier in einem Podcast, welche Rolle Podcasts so spielen können, also inwieweit da Accessibility für so Audio-Inhalte auch definiert sind oder ein Thema sind oder sind die an sich schon Accessibility?
Nee, das kann man so nicht sagen. Man muss es erstmal immer angucken.
Ein kleines Anekdötchen zum Thema Podcasts, was wir in den Benutzertests zum Bean Award von einigen Blinden gehört haben, ist, dass die gerne Podcasts nicht in den integrierten Flashplayern sich anhören, sondern wirklich einen klassischen Lad-Mir-MP3-Link runter haben wollen. Aber nicht, weil Flash böse ist, sondern weil die sich den runterladen und einen anderen Player abspielen und den dann da auf schneller stellen. Weil Blinde enorm darauf trainiert sind, sehr schnell sehr viel Sprache aufnehmen zu können. Also wenn man sich mal neben einen Blinden setzt und dem zuhört, also ein gut trainierter Blinder mit einem wirklich fitter, mit einem Screenreader, hat den auf wie viele Worte pro Minute, würdest du sagen?
Auf jeden Fall ist es nicht so.
Ich verstehe nichts mehr. Ich verstehe kein Wort mehr, weil die die Sprache so schnell gestellt haben. Und das hat aber jetzt nichts mit Accessibility zu tun. Also der Podcast ist natürlich für den Blinden genauso zugänglich, ob er den jetzt schneller machen kann oder nicht. Aber die Darbietung ist auch eine Frage. Das war ein Kriterium, was sehr viele Blinde gesagt haben. Ihre Ansprüche an Podcasts wären, sie wollen den schneller stellen. Das nervt sie, so langsame Sprache, wie wir sehen, miteinander sprechen, hören zu müssen.
Das kann ich nur bestätigen. Auf jeden Fall für alle wieder. Da gibt es ab und zu einen Podcast, da gibt es aber immer einen Transkript. Der Transkript ist auch berechtigt. Und zwar für diejenigen, die einen Podcast nicht hören können. Aber auch nicht nur für Gehörlose, sondern auch für Blinde. Ich lese den Podcast immer im Text mit meinem Screenreader. Das geht einfach viel schneller.
Das heißt, das eigentliche Vorlesen ist schon eher Accessibility für Sehende. Die nicht so gut hören oder verstehen.
Also ich denke, einen Podcast hört man mehr im Hintergrund. Man bügelt oder trinkt seinen Tee oder was weiß ich.
Ja, oder joggt im Wald.
Ja, irgend sowas.
Gruß an alle, die jetzt gerade im Wald joggen.
Ich lese meistens nur Fachbeiträge. Und da will ich möglichst schnell durch. Weil, also teilweise, ich brauche nicht die ständigen Wiederholungen. Ich möchte einfach die neuen Erkenntnisse. Und da bin ich also zehnmal schneller.
Kann ich verstehen. Also, so ein iPod hat ja zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit, wenn es sich um ein Hörbuch handelt, blöderweise nur dann, auch drei, zumindest drei verschiedene Geschwindigkeiten, also langsamer, schneller und normal einzustellen. Das ist natürlich nicht ausreichend. Mir fehlt da auch mal so ein bisschen das Drehrad. Weil es gibt natürlich Leute, die wirklich so in epischer Langsamkeit sprechen. Ich merke das auch immer wieder, wenn ich meine Aufzeichnungen abhöre. Die höre ich nämlich auch in der Regel, naja, so auf anderthalb bis zweieinhalb. Dann ist alles, da setzt es dann bei mir aber auch wirklich aus. Also wer, also wer, ich weiß nicht, wie schnell kann denn der Blinde so hören?
Also ich habe es auf ungefähr vierfache Geschwindigkeit. Ich kenne Leute, die das auf sechsfache haben. Aber wir reden hier nicht über, also das ist die allgemeine Einstellung der Sprachausgabe und das ist eine technische Stimme auch. Ich würde sagen, man trainiert sich ja selbst. Als ich damit angefangen habe, war es ganz langsam. Als ich das besagte Buch in 2004, 2005 geschrieben habe, habe ich das immer intensiver benutzt und immer wieder die Geschwindigkeit erhöht. Und irgendwann habe ich gemerkt, der ist schneller als ich. Ich konnte ja sehr schlecht sehen. Und das war so die Phase, in der ich auf Sparhausgabe umgestiegen bin. Und seitdem hat sich das auch noch beschleunigt.
Ja, vielleicht zum Abschluss nochmal die Frage nach den Ressourcen. Wir haben ja schon einige genannt. Es gibt natürlich die WCAG, über die wir jetzt viel geredet haben und diese WAI-Aria-Spezifikation, die ja auch zum W3C-Projekt gehört. Also WAI steht für Web Accessibility Initiative. Sonst noch irgendwas? Einfach für alle hatten wir erwähnt. Deine alte Webseite, die aktualisiert gehört, aber keine falschen Informationen enthält. Barrierefrei ist webdesign.de. Was würde euch sonst noch so einfallen?
Natürlich der Bienepreis heißt es heutzutage.
Biene-Wettbewerb, da gibt es auch ein Prüfverfahren. Ist auch bei Eva auf den Seiten verlinkt. Wird aber wie jedes Jahr wahrscheinlich auch im nächsten Jahr wieder bearbeitet werden. Das Prüfverfahren. Meine Lieblingsressource im Augenblick ist das Opera Developer Network. Gigantisch gut. Die hauen im Augenblick in einer Frequenzartikel raus. Richtig gute Artikel.
Wovon reden wir von einem Blog?
Von dem Browserhersteller Opera, Odin. Ich weiß nicht, wo das I ist.
Ich auch nicht.
Es ist von Opera und deren Angestellten Fachartikel. Oder von Dritten, die für Opera was geschrieben haben. Richtig toll im Augenblick. Das ist im Augenblick der Stand der Technik, was da veröffentlicht wird. Für jeden, der ein bisschen in der Materie drin steht. Nicht für ganz unten Einsteiger, aber für jeden, der ein bisschen in der Materie drinsteckt.
Es heißt tatsächlich nur Opera Developer Network. Das I haben sie da.
Ach, ist das doch weg, oder was?
Opera, das ist doch auch so Skandinavier. Die haben es doch da mit ihren Göttern.
Wo kommt das A eigentlich? Wasp für Web-Datas? Das wollte ich dich schon immer fragen.
Da müsstest du jetzt den Herrn Zeltmann fragen.
Der hat sich das ausgedacht.
Jeffrey, if you're listening.
Ich glaube, so spricht man dann halt die Abkürzung auf.
Aber es erklärt auch dem natürlich das Akronym Biene. Also eine gewisse Verwandtschaft wird wohl da sein.
Ja, das hatte ich auch schon vermutet.
Das heißt, ich verrate es jetzt doch. Also barrierefreies Internet eröffnet neue Einsichten. Die Ausschreibversion dieses Akronyms ist jünger als das Akronym selber. Was kann man denn aus Biene machen?
Ich möchte auf eine Ressource verweisen, die ist auch gerade in Überarbeitung. Und zwar auch ein Prüfverfahren, die ist nicht ganz so umfangreich wie Biene und vielleicht für Einsteiger besser geeignet. Und zwar ist das der bitvtest.de, das beruht auf die alte bitv, also bitv10 sozusagen. Da sind 50 Prüfschritte, wo man sich ranhangeln kann, wenn man das erste Mal eine Seite auf Barrierefreiheit prüfen möchte.
Also eine Webseite, wo ich einfach nur meine URL eintrage und dann gucke ich mal.
Das würde ich auch unbedingt vermeiden.
Nein, also das ist nicht maschinenprüfbar.
Aber wer sich mal an Chaosradio CCCDE versuchen möchte, dann bin ich für jedes Feedback zu haben.
Eben noch gefragt nach einem einfachen Tipp. Aber eben eine Frage. Einfach ins CSS reinschreiben für Textabsätze, Line height 1.5, Semikolon, Klammer zu, fertig. Also wenn ich Stern geschweifte Klammer auf, Zeilenhöhe 1.5, Semikolon geschweifte Klammer zu, sind 20 Zeichen, die ich ins CSS reinschreiben kann. Kost nichts, tut nicht weh und macht einen gigantischen Unterschied. Das soll wirklich jeder mal ausprobieren.
Die Zeilen einfach ein bisschen zu lockern.
Das ist wirklich der billigste Accessibility-Trick, den man den Leuten nur geben kann. Die Browser setzen Zeilen einfach zu kompress. Das ist einfach zu knirsch, wie Zeilen aneinanderkleben. Und gerade bei langen Zeilen hat das menschliche Auge das Problem, beim Ende der Zeile den Anfang der nächsten Zeile wiederzufinden. Und da hilft mir unheimlich. Das ist eine dramatische Verbesserung in der Lesegeschwindigkeit und damit auch in dem Textverständnis, indem man einfach den Zeilenabstand ein bisschen hochdreht. Also irgendwie so 1,4, 1,5 kommt ein bisschen auf die verwendete Schrift an, ob die jetzt große oder kleine oberen Unterlängen hat und so weiter. Davon hängt es ein bisschen ab. Aber irgendwas so in dem Bereich 1,4, 1,5 mal für alles Mögliche, für alle möglichen Textelemente mal definieren, macht einen riesen Unterschied. Also das ist so mein Gratistipp für heute.
Okay, baue ich gleich ein. Super, so jetzt müssen wir uns auch hier langsam sputen, denn heute Abend ist irgendwie Biene-Award. Ich bin sehr gespannt für das erste Mal da. Ihr ja nicht so, ihr seid ja schon ein alter Hasen. Und ja, ich habe schon so gehört, das ist so ein bisschen die Love Parade der Accessibility-Szene. Da geht es dann auch irgendwie zur Sache bis spät in die Nacht. Ja, ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich sage vielen Dank, Thomas, vielen Dank Jan, für die ausführlichen Darstellungen. Super spannendes Thema. Ich werde da auch versuchen, ran zu bleiben und auch sich möglicherweise neue Themenfelder, wo sie sich anbieten, dann auch hier aufzugreifen. Ja, das war es bei Chaosradio Express. Ausgabe Nummer 107 ist jetzt hier fertig. Nochmal vielen Dank und dann sagen wir schön artig Tschüss. Und Tschüss an die Hörer und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.